justement faut que je dise d'ailleurs du
coup donc merci bonjour
colombe bah tiens voilà il y a de la
place va te mettre à côté de mathde
Marie- piierre voilà
euh voilà bon si tu vous voilà c'est
allez-y euh alors tout d'abord vous dire
que cette audition fait l'objet d'une
captation vidéo
mes chers collègues nous auditionnons
aujourd'hui Mame berangerre Couillard
ministre chargée de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes et de la lutte
contre les discriminations madame la
ministre c'est la première fois que nous
vous accueillons au sein de la
délégation au droits des femmes du Sénat
en audition plainère depuis votre
nomination au gouvernement cette
audition est l'occasion pour vous de
nous présenter les priorités de votre
feuille de route ministérielle et pour
nous de vous interroger sur le
financement de ces ses priorités et sur
le bilan de la politique gouvernementale
en matière d'égalité et de lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes
notamment depuis le Grenel de novembre
2019 en effet la politique
gouvernementale de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes s'inscrit
toujours dans le cadre des mesures
annoncées le 25 novembre 2019 lors du
Grenel de lutte contre les
violences pouvez-vous nous présenter le
bilan chiffré des dispositions mises en
œuvre à ce jour ordonnance de protection
et effective téléphone grave danger
distribué et
opérationnel nombre de places
d'hébergement et leur attribution par
territoire éventuellement le bracelet
antiapprochement en outre la montée en
charge du pack nouveau départ annoncé
par votre prédécesseur l'année dernière
a pris du retard pour quelle raison
quels ont été les obstacles à son
déploiement quels sont les projections
du gouvernement concernant sa
généralisation ce bilan des dispositifs
mise en œuvre dans le cadre de la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
soulève deux questions connexes celle du
pilotage de cette politique publque et
celle du budget qui lui est dédié la
question du pilotage me tient
particulièrement à cœur surtout depuis
la publication du rapport du plan
rougeevf que j'ai corédigé avec notre
collègue député Émilie Chandler
l'absence de coordination
interministériel dans le suivi de
l'application des mesures de lutte
contre les violences et préjudiciables
c'est un point sur lequel le
gouvernement devra me semble-t-il
nettement s'améliorer et il me semble
que c'est un ou une ministre qui devrait
en être chargé et pourquoi pas vous à
condition bien sûr que la première
ministre vous appuie suffisamment pour
gagner les négociations avec les réquel
Citran de façon plus générale en
septembre dernier un rapport de la Cour
des comptes a dénoncé l'absence de
politique continue et coordonnée en
matière d'égalité femmes hommes que
pouvez-vous répondre à ces critiques
ensuite la question du budget est
évidemment primordial les crédits du
programme 137 égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes s'élèvent pour 2024 à 76
millions d'euros en autorisation
d'engagement et en crédit de paiement
soit une augmentation de 16,26 % en
crédit de paiement et de 22,8 % en
autorisation d'engagement par rapport à
la loi de finance initiale pour
2023 l'augmentation des crédits plus 13
millions d'euros constaté à périmètre
courant sur 1 an est presque entièrement
absorbé par la mise en de l'aide
exceptionnelle d'urgence pour les
victimes de violence conjugale issue de
la proposition de loi sénatoriale de
notre ancienne collègue Valérie lettard
toutefois comme l'ont souigné nos
collègues rapporteurs spéciaux de la
commission des finances Éric Boquet et
Arnaud Bazin à périmètre constant les
dépenses en faveur de l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes n'augmenteraiit
que de 0,9 million d'euros en
autorisation d'engagement et connaîtrait
même une diminution de 2,4 millions
d'euros en crédit paiement entre 2023 et
2024 nos collègues de la commission des
finances du Sénat ont également estimé
qu'il convenait de rester vigilant sur
la mise en œuvre de cette aide d'urgence
et rappeler que les associations de
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes ont relevé que le montant budgéé
risquait de n'être pas suffisant pour
assurer une appropriation large de cette
aide par les victimes si elle est
universelle ça n'est pas suffisant sinon
il y a des critères qui peut-être sont
dans le décret mais que jeavoue n'avoir
pas encore lu en outre un certain nombre
d'interrogations entourent encore la
mise en œuvre de cette aide notamment
s'agissant de la concertation en amont
des principaux acteurs concernés par son
application en premier lieu les caisses
d'allocation
familiale plus largement les
associations féministes réclament un
véritable plan Marshal dédié au
financement de la politique de lutte
contre les violence en faveur de
l'égalité estimant qu'aujourd'hui le
compte n'y est pas la Fondation des
femmes a sorti un rapport récemment à ce
sujet je sais qu'on ne peut pas comparer
l'Espagne car au sein des chiffres
annoncés dans le plan espagnol on trouve
tous les financements des les
collectivités également en France si on
ajoutait ce que met l'État à ce que met
l'État les montants consacrés par les
départements les région pour participer
à cette lutte nous aurions probablement
un autre regard ce qui amène une autre
question pourquoi ne pas essayer de
chiffrer ce montant consolidé ainsi nous
pourrions comparer ce qui est comparable
et mesurer l'effort restant à fournir
mais bonne nouvelle les associations
vont pouvoir être financé dans le cadre
de convention
pluriannuelle c'est l'une des
préconisations du en rouge vif et qui a
été annoncé par la première ministre le
24 novembre dernier les associations
l'attendaient pouvez-vous nous apporter
des précision sur le montant des ces
financements pluri-annuels dédiés à la
politique de lutte contre les violences
intrafamiliales d'ici la fin du
quinquena notamment dans le cadre du
plan interministériel pour l'égalité
2023-2027 pour ma part savez vous savez
que je plaide pour la création d'un fond
dédié à la lutte contre les violences
intrafamiliales afin de ne plus entendre
de la la CAF je n'ai pas de ligne pour
ça ou du ministère de la Justice il me
faut un autre coffinanceur
euh je pense particulièrement à un
projet que je vous avais soumis enfin le
gouvernement a annoncé la mise en place
d'un budget genré pour 2025 quelles en
seront les modalités madame la ministre
je vous laisse sans plus tarder la
parole et je proposerai après votre
propos introductif à mes collègues
d'intervenir merci
madame la Présidente chè Dominique
mesdames mesdames uniquement les pardon
excusez je ne vous ai pas vu arriver
vous êtes arrivé plus tard que mesdames
excusez-moi donc mesdames et
monsieurs membres de la délégation au
droits des femmes du Sénat je suis déjà
heureuse d'être d'être devant vous
aujourd'hui vous le soullignez madame la
Présidente c'est l'occasion pour moi de
connaître ma première audition au Sénat
en tant que ministre en charge de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et la lutte contre les discrimination je
voudrais avant toute chose saluer votre
votre élection euh cher Dominique
Verrien en tant que nouvelle présidente
de la délégation aux droits des femmes
du Sénat et vous souhaitez bien sûr le
meilleur pour pour ce mandat et
remercier aussi Annique billon pour son
engagement et l'énergie déployée durant
le précédent mandat à la tête de cette
de cette délégation alors évidemment moi
j'ai été député et membre de la
délégation au droits des femmes de
l'Assemblée nationale et donc j'ai un
profond respect euh pour les délégations
quel qu'elles soit au Sénat et à
l'Assemblée nationale je tenais à vous
le préciser et d'ailleurs je souhaite
aussi la bienvenue à toutes les
nouvelles sénatrices et sénateurs qui
viennent de rejoindre cette délégation
on y fait des travaux formidables et des
travaux interministériels et c'est
toujours extrêmement plaisant de
travailler au sein de de ces délégations
alors cette audition est un passage
obligé auquel j'ai plaisir à me
soumettre parce que je crois dans la
nécessité de vous rendre compte vous
représentants des citoyens français et
particulièrement des collectivités
locales de l'action du gouvernement et
tout particulièrement de mon ministère
la délégation droits des femmes elle
joue un rôle crucial dans l'évaluation
de nos politiques publiques et votre
vigilance constante sur chacune des
politiques qui est mené est
indispensable pour faire progresser la
condition et l'émancipation des femmes
en France et ainsi réduire les
inégalités entre les femmes et les
hommes c'est une plusvalue parce que
depuis depuis 2017 le président de la
République a érigé l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes comme grande cause
de ces deux quinquenas successif et avec
votre appui une action sans précédent a
été engagée notamment pour lutter contre
les violences faites aux femmes ce
second quinquena porte la même ambition
pour la cause des femmes et c'est pour
ça que la première ministre d'ailleurs a
présenté le 8 mars
dernier le plan interministériel pour
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
toutes et tous égaux donc donc le plan
2023-2027 il se décline en 161 mesures
réparties en quatre axes prioritaires
qui Orient l'action des ministères sur
les prochaines années il y a la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
la santé des femmes l'égalité
professionnelle et économique et
également la culture de l'égalité c'est
ainsi qu' a été construite d'ailleurs ma
feuille de route et ce sont les sujets
sur lesquels j'entends mener une action
prioritaire dans notre lutte contre les
violences sex et sexuelle et
particulièrement les violences
conjugales nous avons fait un très grand
pas cette question est devenue
aujourd'hui une préoccupation majeure
qui traverse l'ensemble de la société et
qui interpelle tous les Français vous y
avez nous y avons largement contribué le
grenade et violence conjugale a permis
un débat public exclusivement consacré à
la lutte contre les violences conjugales
nous avons voté cinq textes de loi mis
en place de nombreux dispositifs qui
permettent de mieux protéger les
victimes de violence conjugal et pour
répondre dors et déjà à certaines de vos
questions madame la Présidente nous
pouvons faire un premier bilan de cette
action notre priorité elle a d'abord été
de se concentrer sur le recueil de la
parole des des victimes et ça s'est
traduit vous le savez par l'extension du
soutien aux victimes sur la ligne
téléphonique 3919 7 jours sur 7 24 he/
24 la formation de plus de 150000
policiers gendarmes à ce jour aux
violences intrafamiliales et sexuel euh
je vous indique aussi que 100 % des
élèves de qui sortent de d'écoles de
police et gendarmerie sont aujourd'hui
formé nous avons aussi développé des
dispositifs pour protéger les femmes
notamment le doublement du nombre de
places d'hébergement d'urgence qui sont
passé de 5000 quand nous sommes arrivés
en responsabilité à plus de 10000 en
2023 il y en aura 1000 de plus l'année
prochaine et nous avons également permis
l'attribution de 1000 bracelets
antiraapprochement euh et vous indiquez
aussi pour assurer son déploiement
encore plus largement qu'on a une
nouvelle génération de bracelets qui
arrivve cette fin d'année parce que si
on sait que c'est ça qui qui qui
bloquait parce qu'ils étaient pas
réputés pour être extrêmement efficace
on a également 5000 téléphones graves
danger qui ont été déployés je vous
rassure aussi il y a du stock
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un stock tampon
qui permet de répondre aux urgences donc
il n'y a pas de de difficulté
d'approvisionnement en terme de
téléphone grave danger et puis également
nous avons délivré 6000 ordonnances de
protection ça c'était en 2021 faudrait
que j'ai des éléments de 2022 mais on
doit être sur les même sur des chiffres
un peu plus élevés mais pour vous
indiquer que ça représente tout de même
une augmentation de 90 % depuis que nous
avons passé les lois nécessaires pour
faire baisser les délais d'attribution
quand nous sommes arrivés en
responsabilité il fallait plus de 40
jours pour délivrer une ordonnance de
protection la loi nous a permis de
passer à 6 jours et nous avons
d'ailleurs vous savez l'intention de
passer en 24 heures et ça provient de
votre travail avec Ilie Chandler
notamment le rapport
rougeevf on sait également aussi attaché
à traiter les auteurs
euh en 2020 et 2021 on a ouvert donc 18
centres en 2020 12 centres en 2021 ce
qui représente 30 centres de prise en
charge des auteurs de violence conjugale
c'est il s'agit en fait d'un
accompagnement psychologique social
c'est-à-dire réinsertion à l'emploi et
puis également un traitement des
addictions qui sont souvent rencontrées
chez les auteurs il faut savoir que dans
50 % des féminicides le conjoint est
sous l'emprise de
l'alcool et d'ailleurs c'est pas rare
non plus que les deux soient sous
emprise de l'alcool pendant les pendant
l'effet donc l'idée c'est de traiter les
les les problèmes rencontrés par les
auteurs pour éviter la récidive parce
que la récidive est bien trop importante
encore dans notre pays 40 % de récidives
en moyenne et donc il nous faut
absolument réduire cette récidif parce
que même si l'auteur ne réitère pas avec
la même il réitérera avec une autre et
donc évid évidemment sinon c'est sans
fin
donc aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut savoir
sur ces auteurs qui ont été accompagné
il faut savoir qu'ils étaient 14000
l'année dernière c'est important 90 % de
ces auteurs viennent sous décision de
justice et seulement 10 % viennent sur
la base du volontariat donc ce que je
souhaiterais c'est développer le le
volontariat pour faire en sorte de
prendre le le le mal à la racine et de
traiter beaucoup plus rapidement les
auteurs de violence conjugales parce que
bien sûr il y a des pervers narcissiques
mais il y a aussi des hommes qui ont
besoin de se faire accompagner mais qui
ne savent pas vers qui se tourner et
donc de faire connaître ces centres de
prise en charge pour hauteur ça peut les
aider en tous les cas à créer un déclic
chez eux et et à et à simplement
demander de
l'aide je pense que c'est important
aussi de vous donner des quelques
chiffres sur la la réponse pénale qui a
été donnée il faut savoir Queen 2022 ce
ce sont
49616 condamnations qui ont été
prononcées en 2017 il en avait seulement
22206 donc on a plus que doublé le
nombre de condamnations et 39641
hauteurs ont été éloignés en 2022 contre
seulement 11300 en
2017 malgré le bilan que je vous fais
sur les dispositifs que nous avons
déployés les dispositifs principaux
parce qu'évidemment vous savez ils sont
ils sont beaucoup plus nombreux que cela
moi je crois que et c'est ce que je dis
depuis que je suis arrivé en
responsabilité à ce ministère c'est
qu'il faut avoir l'humilité de dire que
nous sommes pas satisfaits des résultats
et c'est bien pour ça d'ailleurs que
nous allons continuer à agir les les
féminicides ne ne ne baissent pas ou pas
assez pour être mentionné et donc ça
nous oblige à à continuer à déployer des
dispositifs vous avez évoqué madame la
Présidente le sujet de l'Espagne parce
que c'est un pays pionnier que nous
regardons avec évidemment beaucoup
d'intérêt l'Espagne il a fallu 7 ans
pour connaître les chiffres qui décroi
en terme de de féminicide al évidemment
l'objectif c'est pas d'attendre 7 ans
c'est bien d'avancer plus vite mais
c'est aussi pour dire que en fait il ne
suffit pas de déployer des dispositifs
pour qu'il fonctionnent dans l'immédiaté
et donc il faut aussi s'assurer de leur
déploiement de leur bon fonctionnement
et donc c'est aussi ma mission
c'est-à-dire quand je j'ai pris ce cette
responsabilité à ce ministère j'ai j'ai
souhaité autant évaluer les politiques
que nous avons engagé que de déployer
les nouvelles politiques sur lequell il
est indispensable de continuer de de de
continuer à à agir parce que nous avons
une nécessité de de répondre à l'urgence
l'urgence c'est bien les féminicide dans
notre pays alors quand je disais qu'on
allait continuer à déployer des
dispositifs on a rapidement évoqué
l'ordonnance de protection donc on va
passer à un délai de 24 heures pour des
ordonnances donc urgentes ordonnan de
protection urgente donc ça c'est une
proposition du plan rouge vif ça montre
aussi qu'il y a évidemment un travail
nourri des parlementaires au Sénat bien
sûr et à l'Assemblée nationale et ce qui
permet donc de pouvoir avoir des des des
des propositions qui puissent être
prises et donc ça ce sera très
prochainement que nous allons voter
cette cette proposition de loi qui
passera je crois d'abord à l'Assemblée
nationale puis puis au Sénat il y a
également la création des pôles
spécialisés dans les violence
intrafamiliale dans toutes nos
juridictions qui une action aussi
puissante vous savez qu'il est
absolument nécessire qu'il y a davantage
de communication entre le civil et le
pénal parce que je suis persuadé que ça
permettra de mieux accompagner les
victimes et puis on souhaite faciliter
les séparations des victimes des
agresseurs c'est pour ça qu'on déploie
le pack nouveau- départ et l'aide
d'urgence sur lesquels vous m'avez
d'ailleurs
interrogé en moyenne il faut 7
aller-retour pour que les femmes
quittent le
domicile définitivement et donc qu'elle
arrive qu'elles arrivent à quitter leur
leur bourreau et donc on souhaite
développer ce dispositif du pack nouveau
départ dans cinq départements le
valdoise a été en préexpérimentation le
lot etgaron les bouche du rô la Côte
d'Or et la Réunion c'est pour cette fin
d'année je voudrais vous indiquer madame
la Présidente parce que c'est les propos
que vous avez tenus il n'y a pas de
retard il n'a jamais été question de
lancer avant l'été sur les cinq
départements l'idée était bien d'avoir
un département précurseur qui euh fait
les préexpérimentations pour qu'on
s'assure d'avoir un dispositif qui
fonctionne dans les qu autres
départements sur lesquels ça va déployer
donc ce sera le cas cette fin d'année
donc il y a pas de retard donc réalisé
moi j'ai j'ai fait un un comité de
pilotage il y a maintenant une semaine
10 jours dans le valdoise donc ça
fonctionne bien euh toutes les enfin ça
a été bien testé par les agents les
agents de de la CAF il y a plus d'une
vingtaine de femmes qui ont été
accompagnées et donc maintenant on peut
le déployer dans les quatre autres
départements
et on va comme ça s'assurer qu'il y ait
un bon fonctionnement du du nouveau
dispositif faut savoir d'ailleurs que ça
nécessité un long travail d'ingénierie
pour mettre en place cela et donc il n'y
a pas de de vraiment de de retard sur
sur ce sur ce dispositif vous avez parlé
de l'aide
d'urgence donc que vous avez créé grâce
à la loi du 28 février 2023 qui est une
mesure forte qui donc va être mis en
place à partir tir du 1er
décembre c'était en date c'était bien
prévu à partir du 1er décembre la seule
chose c'est qu'on éétait pas certain
d'avoir les crédits donc ça nous a on
pouvait mettre en place évidemment le
dispositif mais l'idée c'était bien
d'avoir les crédits et donc moi j'ai
choisi de débloquer 1,5 million d'euros
dès décembre c'était des crédits qui
avaient pas été prévus donc sur le PLF
donc 2023 mais l'idée c'est d'être
évidemment prêt tout de suite pour une
mise en œuvre au 1er des décembre et
donc 1,5 million d'euros seront
consacrés dès décembre pour l'aide
d'urgence sachant que vous le savez 10
millions d'euros ont été sont consacrés
pour l'année prochaine pour l'aide
d'urgence c'est bien donc 10 millions
supplémentaires sur mon budget qui sont
consacrés pour cette pour cette aide
d'urgence
euh on est également en train de
réfléchir à un meilleur accompagnement
des enfants qui sont victimes
collatérales de violence conjugale parce
que la lutte contre les violences faites
aux femmes inclut aussi la lutte euh la
lutte contre les violences faites faites
aux enfants et c'est évidemment
indispensable qu'on puisse regarder cela
je sais que vous l'avez également
travaillé dans le cadre du plan rouge
juif la lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes inclut aussi la lutte
contre l'exploitation et la traite des
êtres humains en France il faut savoir
que l'exploitation sexuelle est la
première forme d'exploitation les
victimes de traite des êtres humains ont
identifié par les forces de l'ordre les
forces de sécurité intérieure et
accompagné par les associations sont en
majorité des femmes victimes
d'exploitation sexuelle c'est un combat
que nous poursuivons parce que si la loi
de 2016 est un signal important son
application réelle complète nécessite
encore des efforts je porterai donc un
3oisème plan national de lutte contre la
traite des êtres humains et en parallèle
avec Charlotte cobel une première
stratégie nationale de lutte contre le
système prostitutionnel nous avons
choisi de renforcer la loi de 2016 dans
tous ces aspects les commissions
départementales les parcours de sortie
de prostitution la pénalisation des
clients l'utilisation de l'ensemble des
moyens de l'aide financière à
l'insertion sociale qui sont destiné au
parcours de sortie de prostitution enfin
j'ai envie d'arrêter votre attention sur
le sujet des femmes faites au dans
l'industrie pornographique je sais que
la délégation aux droits des femmes du
Sénat est tout particulièrement engagée
sur le sujet et je souhaite vraiment
saluer de nouveau la qualité du travail
que vous avez fourni l'année dernière
dans le dans le cadre du rapport porno
l'enfer du décor que vous avez publié
d'ailleurs en septembre
2022 j'ai eu l'occasion d'échanger avec
il y a quelques semaines dans ces murs
avec les rapporteurs et le rapport
réalisé aussi par le Haut Conseil à
l'égalité plus récemment a réaffirmé et
documenté l'ampleur des violences faites
aux femmes dans l'industrie
pornographique la lutte contre ces
violences est vraiment une priorité de
mon mandat et figure à ce titre
explicitement dans ma feuille de route
j'ai donc initié un groupe de travail
interministériel avec avec les
ministères de l'intérieur de la justice
du travail de la culture du numérique
pour aborder le sujet dans ces
différentes dimension et je vous annonce
aussi que le ministère de la Santé nous
a également rejoint dans ce travail nous
travaillerons dans les prochains mois à
faire émerger expertiser des mesures sur
le retrait des contenus contenant des
tortures et actes de barbarie le droit à
l'oubli et au retrait donc des contenus
lorsque la personne concernée le demande
et le respect du droit du travail je
sais l'attente force de la délégation
sur ces sujets et je veux vraiment salu
saluer l'implication sans faille de ses
membres pour les faire avancer dans un
un autre domaine en matière de de santé
des femmes de belles victoires ont été
obtenues ces dernières années et il
s'agit maintenant de concrétiser
nombreux engagements vous savez dans le
il y a plusieurs mesures dans le PLFSS
qui sont à saluer notamment le
remboursement des préservatifs féminins
pour les jeunes jusqu'à 26 ans après
avoir concrétisé le remboursement des
préservatifs masculins ce qui a eu
d'ailleurs les résultats escomptés la
prise en charge des des protections
périodiques réutilisables pour toutes
les femmes jusqu'à 26 ans et pour toutes
celles sans limite d'âge d'ailleurs
bénéficiaire de la complémentaire santé
solidaire c'est près de quand même de 4
millions de femmes et puis également
l'élargissement de la compétence des
pharmaciens sur les sistites simples
cela permettra de traiter 80 % des
pathologies sans attend d'avoir un
rendez-vous chez le médecin je sais que
votre délégation est particulièrement
attentive sur la santé des femmes comme
le prouve l'un de vos rapports publ publ
en juin dernier vos 23 propositions
concrètes détaillées nous les regardons
avec attention je peux vous en assurer
mais la mesure sur laquelle nous sommes
le plus attendus je crois c'est celle de
la constitutionalisation de l'IVG les
événements de l'année dernière aux
États-Unis particulièrement nous
rappelle à quel point les droits des
femmes peuvent être fragiles en 18 mois
14 États américains ont interdit l'IVG
des femmes risquent aujourd'hui la
prison tout simplement pour avoir
recours à à l'avortement donc je crois
pouvoir dire que face aux ambiguïtés de
certains partis d'extrême droite même de
notre pays nous ne sommes pas à l'abri
et donc le président de la République en
annonçant le dépôt du d'un projet de loi
constitutionnel envoi un signal fort
pour assurer son allèement que rien ne
pourra entraver ou défaire cette liberté
inhérente aux femmes celle-ci sera
inscrite dans notre texte fondamental et
sera donc irréversible c'est aussi un
message universel de solidarité à toutes
les femmes qui aujourd'hui se voient à
cette liberté bafouée et grâce au
travail parlementaire issu de
l'Assemblée nationale puis du Sénat
grâce au travail transpartisan
consensueux vous avez réalisé je crois
qu'il est temps de saisir ce moment
historique ce moment politique de
consensus donc le projet constitutionnel
a été soumis au Conseil d'État il sera
présenté en Conseil des ministres le 13
décembre prochain et nous irons au bout
de la promesse faite par le Président de
la République l'idée c'est l'idéal
serait d'aboutir au mois de mars
à nous d'être à nous d'être
efficace notre pays progresse également
vers une Réal une réelle égalité
professionnelle nous avons fait beaucoup
de chemins depuis que nous sommes en
responsabilité les résultats confirment
que nous empruntons une trajectoire
positive le revenu salarial moyen des
femmes en France est encore inférieur de
24 % à celui des hommes dans le secteur
privé en 2021 à poste comparable l'écart
salarial en équivalent en plein il est
de de 4,3 %. nous avons déjà commencé à
agir sur les écarts salariaux à poste
égal nous devons maintenant agir sur les
autres écarts salariaux et l'une des
problématiques majeures ce sont les
temps partiels subis pour les éviter je
crois dans un premier temps il nous faut
travailler sur les modes de garde des
enfants l'aide à la garde d'enfants pour
les familles monoparentales est déjà
passé de 6 à 12 ans l'allocation de
soutien familial a été augmentée de 50 %
pour atteindre 185 5 € par enfant et par
mois dès novembre 2022 et nous allons
créer le service public de la petite
enfance en parallèle nous déployons
actuellement le plan toutes et tous
égaux et lors de la conférence sociale
la première ministre a annoncé qu'il
nous fallait bâtir un nouvel index
égalité professionnelle pour corriger
tout simplement les billets de l'indexe
existant les concertations avec les
partenaires sociaux débuteront à partir
de ce mois de janvier celui-ci devrait
être plus ambitieux plus transparent
plus fiable et mieux contrôlé et
également servir aussi dans le cadre des
négociations entre les syndicats le
patronat nous en profiterons pour mettre
en œuvre l'ég conditionnalité de la
commande publique parce que je crois que
c'est évidemment indispensable pour agir
sur l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes et enfin je suis assez fierè de
pouvoir vous dire que nous avançons sur
la question de la budgétisation
intégrant l'égalité vous en avez parlé
madame la Présidente je viens ancier une
mission en collaboration avec l'IGF
liigas et le sdfe pour que la mise en
œuvre de cette mesure soit effective dès
le PLF et PLFSS
2025 les travaux de la mission porteront
sur les budgets de l'État et également
sur la sécurité sociale et la mission
remettra son rapport final au printemps
2024 je veux aussi que nous avanionons
pour concrétiser la culture de l'égalité
que nous appelons toutes et tous de nos
vœux ici et cela pass j'en suis
convaincu par l'éducation dès le plus
jeune âge vous le savez il y a un
rapport de l'inspection générale de
l'éducation du sport et de la recherche
qui a été publié en septembre 2022 qui
relève qui révèle pardon qu'il y a moins
de 15 % des élèves qui bénéficient des
trois séances d'éducation à la sexualité
pendant l'année scolaire nous souhaitons
agir et c'est pour répondre à ce besoin
que le Conseil supérieur des programmes
a été saisi le 23 juin dernier pour
élaborer justement un nouveau programme
euh vous rassurez aussi sur le fait que
les associations féministes et LGBT sont
totalement intégrés euh notamment et
sont consultés régulièrement à réception
donc de ce nouveau programme il est
prévu en tout cas qu'il y a un avis du
Conseil supérieur des programmes donc à
partir du mois de décembre donc c'est
incessamment sous peu nous allons à
réception donc de ce nouveau programme
former le personnel enseignant le
personnel de l'éducation nationale ça
nous permettra d'intervenir sur
l'ensemble des thématiques qui ont été
retenues et les associations bien sûr
auront toujours leur part d'intervention
attention parce qu'elles interviendront
sur des des des sujets qui peuvent être
complémentaires au aux sujets qui ont
déjà été abordé par par le corps
enseignant nous espérons donc que c
cette ces nouvelles générations de
citoyens
auront tous les les clés en main pour
appréhender le monde avec respect et
bienveillance c'est bien ça l'objectif
et nous avons aussi parfaitement
conscience que pour la pleine réussite
de la mise en œuvre de ces séances il
faudra rassurer les parents les familles
sur le contenu qui sera enseigné à nos
élèves nous travaillons en ce sens donc
avec la publication du programme par le
Conseil supérieur des programmes qui
sera je crois pouvoir dire un premier
gage de confiance jusque-l l'application
de cette loi n'a pas fonctionné parce
que elle était trop aléatoire sur les
territoires que les associations ne sont
pas assez nombreuses pour répondre à la
demande si toutes les les établissement
on faisait la demande en même temps et
également nous n'avions pas de contenu
uniformisé
donc notre ambition politique sur tous
les sujets que je viens d'évoquer elle
s'accompagne d'un budget pour 2024 et ce
sera les les dernier mot que que que
j'aurais je crois que c'est le c'est sur
le sujet du budget vous m'avez
d'ailleurs interrogé sur cette question
du pilotage et du budget donc le budget
alloué au programme 137 pour 2024
s'élève à 76 millions d'euros soit comme
je vous l'ai dit une hausse de 10
millions d'euros pour financer l'aide
d'urgence dans le document de politique
transversale vous pouvez même observer
que l'ensemble des budgets alloué par
les ministères en faveur des violences
faites aux femmes dépasse le
demimilliard contre donc 475 millions
d'euros en 2023 un nouvel effort
budgétaire significatif est ainsi
réalisé dans le cadre du PLF 2024 en
faveur de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes je le rappelle grande cause
nationale qui perdure pour ce quinquena
le comité interministériel à l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes sous
l'autorité de la première minise sera
réuni euh et ça c'était un engagement
chaque année pour suivre l'avancement de
ce plan et et donc il le sera en début
d'année
prochaine bien sûr nous ne réussirons
pas seul et il est indispensable que
nous ayons ce travail transpartisan je
crois que c'est primordial de de le
rappeler et ici c'est le cas l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes doit tous
nous concerner peu importe notre
sensibilité politique et de la
composition de cette délégation
évidemment l'illustration de cela moi je
l'ai mesuré à Genève lors de l'audition
devant le comité de la Convention
la France est leader sur ces sujets et
toutes les femmes à travers le monde
portent leur espoir sur notre capacité à
faire avancer encore davantage la cause
des femmes donc vous pouvez compter sur
moi pour en être garante et je suis
maintenant prête à répondre à toutes vos
questions
merci merci madame la ministre pour vos
propos donc je me tourne vers mes
collègues alors j'ai déjà une demande de
parole d'Annick billon je alors on va
les faire trois par trois si vous voulez
euh ensuite Mariepierre harmonier
euh bon ça ça va être ça va être tout le
monde bon on va déjà faire euh Annique
Billon et Marie-Pierre monniier et je
prends dans la suite merci madame la
Présidente merci madame la ministre pour
les nombreuses réponses déjà apportées
donc je vais poser quelques questions
alors tout d'abord je voudrais vous
interroger sur l'endométriose euh
puisque il y a eu une proposition loi
qui a été rejetée à l'Assemblée
nationale et que vous vous êtes dites
favorable à à un décret pour pour
pouvoir apporter des réponse vous êtes
dit également favorable à un texte plus
large donc euh quel contenu dans quel
délai et quel et quel décret à quel
moment puisque une des mesures
principales de la proposition de loi
était effectivement de d'accorder le
statut al aux femmes victimes
d'endométriose à partir du moment où je
parle d'endomé trio je peux pas
m'empêcher de de voir le système
extrêmement lucratif qui a été mis en
place faute faute finalement de de
spécialistes qu'on puiss que les les
victimes enfin les victimes plutôt les
les patientes peuvent trouver puisque
finalement cette rareté des spécialistes
amène souvent les patientes à se tourner
vers des médecines alternatives ou des
pseudothérapeutes ou sinon à payer des
interventions ex extrêmement cher il y a
la start-up par exemple kiffe ton cycle
qui propose des formations en ligne
payantes allant de 79 à 225 € kiffe ta
ménopause kiffe tes règles sans douleur
kiffe ton endométriose donc il y a un
certain nombre d'outils qui se
développent faute finalement d'une
réponse adaptée en terme de soins ou en
terme de de de de spécialistes en
réalité donc en en y regardant de plus
près sur ce site d'ailleurs la la
dernière formation propose ainsi un état
des lieux de la maladie de modifier son
alimentation pour mieux contrôler ses
émotions et de vivre pleinement malgré
l'endométriose donc de jolis slogans qui
ont des ont un coût un prix pour toutes
ces patientes donc je voudrais savoir
est-ce que vous avez étudié ce ce qui se
développe sur les Internet et quelle
réponse pouvez-vous y apporter puisque
c'est un sujet qui concerne énormément
de femmes et donc sur aussi la le côté
législatif puisqueil y avait cette
proposition de loi qui n'a pas fait qui
qui s'est arrêté très rapidement à
l'Assemblée nationale sur les
ordonnances de protection la présidente
vous a interroger euh vous avez indiqué
un délai de 24 he on peut tous se
réjouir il y a aussi la la durée de la
l'ordonnance de protection qui est un
sujet notre collègue hier Laurence
vous interrogeait sur un cas dramatique
ce weekend et vous avez évoqué comme
autre outil aussi le le nouveau pack le
PCT nouveau départ pardon l'aide
d'urgence avec la proposition de Valérie
lard aussi je voudrais vous interroger
moi sur le PCT nouveau- départ on a vu
qu'il était expérimenté sur cinq
départements euh l'aide d'urgence qui
est la résultante de la proposition de
notre collègue Valérie lard c'esténatri
du Nord elle avait expérimenté sur son
territoire sur son département sur ça et
donc c'était tout à fait opérationnel
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas compte
tenu des chiffres des violences
intrafamiliales des violences conjugales
des violences faites aux femmes que
finalement cette expérimentation aurait
mérité d'être plus large au-delà de ces
cinq départements puisqu'il y a une
vraie urgence à
répondre et à apporter des réponses par
rapport au nombre de victimes par
rapport au nombre de
féminicides ensuite je voulais
intervenir sur l'hébergement d'urgence
j'étais lundi à luusson le sud Vendé je
suis sénatrice de la Vendé nous avons
avec Monsieur le Préfet les associations
le département l'intercommunalité
inaugurer un nouveau logement d'urgence
et je souhaite saluer l'engagement de
l'État puisque ce nouveau logement
d'urgence a été possible grâce à
l'engagement de l'État très important
dans le dispositif en même temps nous
sommes alertter au niveau de de de de la
presse par rapport au diminution accordé
du nombre de nuités dans certains
territoires et je pense à Toulouse
notamment donc je voudrais vous poser la
question est-ce que le nombre de places
euh nombre de places avec des
hébergements d'urgence puisqu'il y a à
nouveau 10000 vous en avez créé 10000 il
y en aura 1000 à la fin de l'année
prochaine est-ce que ça s'accompagne
finalement d'une diminution d'énuité
est-ce qu'il y a un effet basculement
parce que auquel cas on a'ura toujours
pas plus de placees même s'il y a 1000
hébergements de plus donc c'est une
question la presse c'est faite la PQR
s'est faite l'écho de de ce cas à à à
Toulouse et dans le département euh et
puis pour conclure je voudrais vous
remercier pour les mots que vous avez eu
évidemment à mon encontre tout à l'heure
au début de votre intervention en salant
la nouvelle présidente et
euh je voudrais dire que les violences
la grande cause du quinquen c'était en
2017 les violences conjugales
intrafamiliales le nombre de féminicides
ne chute pas c'est une
réalité malgré les budgets malgré les
places les places malgré la la
législation qui
évolue nous avons auditionné avec la
commission culture Gabriel Atal
récemment dans le cadre du projet de loi
de finances et moi j'ai été extrêmement
surprise de voir que finalement euh pour
les cours d'éducation à la sexualité on
en était toujours au même point or euh
le Sénat alerte depuis des années sur
les trois séances par an et par niveau
euh il y a urgence alors vous avez
évoquer nos travaux de sur la
pornographie nous nous éduquons des
générations entières depuis des années
2000 à la pornographie avec enfin à la
sexualité avec la pornographie donc
quand est-ce qu'on va avoir cette
volonté politique parce que si on est
toujours sur les contenus j'ai souvenir
que le les deux
prédécesseur de Gabriel Atal du ministre
Gabriel Atal avait déjà travaillé sur
des référentiels qui nous les avait
adressés donc je crois que les outils on
les avait il existe dans de nombreux
pays des outils qui existent déjà donc
moi je pense que sur ce sujet on manque
de moyens parce que les associations ne
pourront pas tout mais on manque
vraiment on a manqué jusqu'àors d'une
une vraie volonté politique pour
appliquer cette loi et je suis trop
longue madame la Présidente donc je
voudrais dire que tant qu'on aura on ne
s'attaquera pas à l'industrie de la
pornographie on n'avancera pas sur la
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes parce que les modèles qui sont
véhiculés dans cette industrie et bien
c'est on peut se permettre la barbarie
avec les femmes l'image des femmes est
extrêmement dégradé et pour avoir
participé à une réunion au Giroir
vendredi dernier et avoir entendu le
témoignage d'une jeune fille de 20 ans
désormais qui avait 14 ans au moment des
faits ce qu'elle a réussi à faire et ce
qu'elle ce qu'elle a fait en terme de
vidéo à 14 ans est totalement effroyable
donc il y a urgence je vous remercie
madame la ministre
merci cher anque je passe la parole du
coup à
ma à Mariepierre Monier allez merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues moi je veux d'abord
rebondir sur les places d'urgence vous
en avez parlé mais je peux vous dire que
sur le terrain c'est compliqué parce que
il ne faut je vois moi beaucoup d'élus
qui sont volontaires ou interco pour
créer pour donner des logements qu'ils
ont qu'ils dédi au à l'accueil de femmes
qui sont victimes de violence mais après
il faut un accompagnement et je
rejoindrai la la question de
d'anck on a eu le sentiment qu'il y a eu
moins de moyens en tout cas pour cette
année 2022 pour accompagner les femmes
parce que c'est pas seulement les mettre
à l'abri c'est parfois aider par exemple
en en payant les fluides et puis tout
l'accompagnement qui doit être là donc
il y a eu je crois une enquête de méiaap
en septembre 2023 qui a pointé ça qui
fait état des directives préfectorales
concernant l'hébergement de femmes en
détresse c'est un constat inquiétant
parce que les associations qui
accompagnent les femmes de victime de
violence seraient contraintes de refuser
à certaines d'entre elles une prise en
charge et de réduire la voilure du
nombre deunités hôtelières d'urgence
qu'elles accordent dans une logique de
gestion de la pénuriie des des
hébergement d'urgence donc j'aimerais
vraiment votre sentiment moi aussi
là-dessus vous avez parlé de l'éducation
dans la vie sexuelle et affective c'est
un sujet qui nous a préoccupé pendant
des années au sein de la délégation et
nous avions demandé d'ailleurs qu'un
qu'un état des lieux soit fait il est
sorti cet état des lieux et vous l'avez
bien précisé tout à l'heure avec des
chiffres qui sont très inquiétants quant
à la tenue moi je suis inquiète des
propos que le ministre de l'Éducation
Gabriel tal puisque c'est dans ses mains
puisque c'est au sein de l'éducation
nationale qu'elles ont lieu ces heures
d'éducation à sexuelle et affective
parce que il nous a dit textuellement
qu'il ne faut pas les c'est cours au
fantasme et à l'instrumentalisation donc
ça moi ça m'a fortement interpellé je
sens que vous reprenez ses propos de
travailler de former le personnel
enseignant c'est bien de travailler avec
les programmes j'espère que ce ne sont
pas que des programmes d'éducation à la
sexualité ou à la reproduction parce
qu'il y a aussi tout un travail de
déconstruction de stéréotypes de genre
de d'éducation au consentement j'espère
que vous me rassurerez sur le
sujet manque de moyens humains des
services des droits droit des femmes au
moandrome j'ai une déléguée
départementale qui est absolument
extraordinaire mais je crois qu'il y a
eu un un rapport de la Cour des comptes
qui dit que la politique d'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes menées par
l'État ben ce sont des avancées limitées
par rapport aux objectifs fixés qui
aurait besoin de d'avantage donc est-ce
que vous prévoyez de renforcer les
effectifs humains de ces services des
droits des femmes et enfin vous savez je
suis une rurale et je m'occupe beaucoup
de aux femmes dans les territoires
ruraux nous avons fait un beau rapport
que je crois je vous ai envoyé sur
femmes et rural été nous avions euh et
en ruralité il y a bien sûr les
associations comme le cdff ou autres qui
font des permanences mais après ce sont
des petites associations qui sont sur le
terrain et qui sont au plus près des
femmes qui sont victimes de violence et
elles le font avec les moyens qu'elles
ont mais elles ont aussi besoin de
moyens or force de constater que les
appels à projets qui sont proposés vont
généralement aux grandes associations
c'est loin de moi idée qu'il faut
enlever aux grandes associations qui
font là aussi un travail extraordinaire
mais elles ont souvent moins
d'ingénierie c'est plus compliqué pour
elles de répondre aux appels à projet et
pourtant je le redis vous savez que
parmi tous les féminicides en France 50
% ont lie en territoireau alors qu'un
seul un/ers seulement des familles
vivent de l'alcool je ne sais pas Madame
la sinatrice mais en tout cas je sais
que la violence est là elle est forte et
qu'elle a besoin d'être accompagné et
que ces petites structures ont vraiment
besoin d'être prises en considération et
enfin quelque chose qui était apparu
aussi comme nécessaire dans ce rapport
c'était la nécessité de nommer un
référent égalité au sein des conseils
municipaux ça veut pas dire une
délégation pour un adjoint avec
financement parce que je reprends mes
communes rurales le maire est en
première ligne c'est-à-dire que c'est
lui qui va être en lien avec ses
administré pour des tas de choses qui ne
dépensent qui ne concernent pas
forcément la gestion d'une commune mais
moi après il se retourne vers moi et je
me disais que si il y avait un référent
en brisie un référent en défense
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai essayé de
porter un amendement au Sénat qui n'a
pas été voté parce que les gens ont
compris comme quoi c'était une dépense
supplémentaire pour les communes
peut-être que vous pourriez prendre un
décret et on pourrait envisager
peut-être des formations j'en sais rien
mais en tout cas qu'il a un référent par
commune ça le serait je sais que
l'association des m ruraux a décidé de
nommer un référent par département c'est
quelque chose moi je pense que c'est
mieux un par comm ou mais c'est par
commune lesuségalité des non moi sur mon
départ non moi quand je lesi rencontréné
ils m'ont bien dit par département et
pour parler des problèmes d'addiction
plus général c'est une un vrai sujet en
effet de s'occuper des problèmes
d'addiction des de toutes personnees
d'ailleurs que ce soit les conjoints
violents ou
pas je vous propose de répondre déjà à
ces deux séries qui sont déjà bien
nourres ensuite on passera la parole à
Laurence Rossignol Lord D'cos et Marie
Mercier mais j'ai bien noté des
merci Madame la la présidente en effet
c'est déjà bien nourri donc je vais
commencer par répondre à Madame billon
sur différents sujet vous m'interrogez
notamment sur
l'endométriose j'ai eu à prendre
position en effet c'était dans le cadre
d'une interview radio et ensuite il y a
eu une dépêche à FP sur le fait que je
souhaitais avancer sur un décret dans le
cadre de de surtout c'est dans le cadre
de pour répondre à la loi et à la
proposition de loi qui était proposée
par le rassemblement national ma
première volonté a étit surtout de
contrer le rassemblement national j'en
fais un un un principe personnel c'est
un engagement aussi politique pour moi
et donc il est mettit insupportable de
d'avoir une reprise politique quelle
qu'elle soit sur le droit des femmes de
la part du rassemblement national
au-delà de ça en fait ma ma ma position
tenait sur le fait que il fallait qu'on
renforce l'existant parce parce qu'on
avait déjà lancé un plan
endométriose ça c'était en 2021 et donc
l'idée c'était de dire comment on peut
faire connaître davantage le les
dispositifs déjà existants on a choisi
de renforcer le le décret al31 parce
qu'en fait il était déjà existant et
l'idée c'est de donner des moyens donc
ces 30 millions d'euros qui sont donnés
notamment à la recherche et vous avez
raison aujourd'hui beaucoup de femmes se
tournent vers des on va dire la médecine
alterna
parce qu'en fait elles ne se sentent pas
assez accompagné dans leur pathologie et
dans les difficultés qu'elle qu'elles
peuvent rencontrer au quotidien euh
d'ailleurs l'important en fait la
première chose c'est de faire connaître
l'endométriose et la faire diagnostiquer
c'est bien pour ça qu'en fait on a C CTA
si je m'en souviens bien c'était en
septembre oui c'était le 4 octobre même
4 octobre j'étais avec le ministre de la
santé à Rennes où on a fait justement un
comité de pilotage sur l'endométriose
pour mesurer en fait l'engagement des
régions des régions parce que les ARS
sont emparés de ce sujet et aussi de
travailler en fait à ce que les les
professionnels de santé soit
particulièrement sensibilisé sur ce
sujet euh parce qu'en fait il y a une
méconnaissance des symptômes et donc
forcément il y a une il y a un mauvais
diagnostic donc ça on travaille beaucoup
à ce que il y ait mise en réseau des des
des professionnels de santé il y a aussi
et de plus en plus des associations de
victimes victime parce qu'elles sont
elles sont en tous les cas elles ont des
ell elles subissent cette cette maladie
et donc il y a de plus en plus
d'associations aussi qui se constitue
pour pouvoir accompagner les femmes qui
souffrent d'endométriose et qui souvent
n'ont pas la capacité de pouvoir en
parler autour d'elles des difficultés
qu'ell peuvent qu'elles peuvent
rencontrer donc euh c'était surtout ça
en tout cas ma ma ma ma
position vous avez raison il faut encore
mieux diagnostiquer cette maladie faire
en sorte que soit mieux pris en charge
c'est bien tout le l'engagement de de ce
décretd31 avec la la les moyens
complémentaires et la mise en réseau des
professionnels de santé pour faire en
sorte que ces femmes ne se sentent pas
délaissé et qu'elles n'aillent pas
verser verser ces traitement alternatifs
qui on sait ne soulage en rien et ces
femmes et donc peuvent les mettre en
grande en grande difficulté euh sur le
l'hébergement d'urgence euh donc comme
je vous disais on a augmenté
sensiblement on a doublé même le nombre
d'hébergements d'urgence qui sont dédiés
aux femmes victimes de violence
conjugale vous me parlez
particulièrement de de Toulouse
euh alors c'est intéressant parce que
moi j'ai discuté avec le préfet il y a
quelques semaines maintenant lors d'un
déplacement que j'ai pu faire à à
Toulouse et il me disait au combien en
effet il y avait des tensions en terme
d'hébergement d'urgence urence mais là
c'est tout tout confondu c'est-à-dire
que faut savoir qu'en France on a 220000
places d'hébergement d'urgence donc
c'est vraiment très important il y a
plus y avoir des tensions pour
accueillir des femmes en précarité
pourquoi parce qu'en fait il est
difficile de sortir des personnes qui
sont qui occupent déjà des hébergement
d'urgence alors que ce sont des parcours
migrants ou d'autres difficultés des
personnes tout simplement à la rue donc
c'est aussi ça la la la réalité des des
préfets et la difficulté de de répartir
les places je tiens quand même à dire
que la priorité elle est donnée aux
femmes victimes de violence et victime
aussi de violence de la de de violence
prostitutionnelle donc toutes les femmes
victimes de violence conjugale et
victime de violence prostitutionnelle
elles sont aussi et surtout privilégié
lorsqu'elles fait font une demande au
1115 donc là-dessus les tensions qui a
pu qui a pu être être présente c'était
sur un moment où il y avait une très
forte pression notamment sur ce
département mais ce n'est pas une
généralité les femmes victimes de
violence sont vraiment prioritaires dans
l'attribution des places d'hébergement
d'urgence après plus globalement et je
me permets de de de de d'englober le
sujet des de l'hébergement par c'est
voilà autant que je fasse le lien mais
je reviendrai bien sûr sur les autres
questions que vous m'avez que vous
m'avez formuler
euh il faut qu' moi je me suis engagé en
fait à regarder plus largement parce que
je crois pas qu'il faille parler
uniquement en quantitatif il faut aussi
qu'on regarde le qualitatif aujourd'hui
on a des hébergements d'urgence qui
semblent ne pas adapté euh aux femmes
euh lorsqu'elles partent précipitamment
de leur domicile et encore moins
lorsqu'elles sont accompagnées d'enfants
il y a aussi pour avoir des retours
terrain des euh logements qui certes ne
sont pas adaptés donc déjà évidemment
euh euh à la famille accueillie mais en
plus qui ne serait pas
digne donc il faut qu'on regarde la
qualité des du du parc d'hébergement
d'urgence pour justement se rendre
compte euh de faire un constat et faire
des actions correctrices nécessair donc
moi je vais lancer ça en début d'année
je vais je commence déjà à travailler
avec le cabinet de de patrist vergrit
donc au au au logement pour justement
mener euh un état des lieux de
l'hébergement d'urgence en France
particulièrement celui dédié aux
violences conjugales mais je vais devoir
regarder beaucoup plus largement ce qui
va nous permettre aussi de lever le
voile sur notamment les difficultés de
création de place d'hébergement
lorsqu'il y a une volonté locale donc là
il faut qu'on regarde voyez ça a bien
fonctionner en Vendé avec du coup vous
l'avez souligné madame billon le le
l'apport de l'État et j'entends ici ou
même à d'autres à d'autres moments des
des places d'hébergement qui ne se
créeraient pas ou difficilement dans
d'autres territoires alors qu'il y a la
volonté des maires des élus locaux et
cetera donc il faut qu'on regarde
vraiment comment naissent ces projets
est-ce à l'initiative uniquement du
Préfet et du corps préfectoral local ENF
il y a beaucoup de choses à regarder et
donc je m'engage à le faire dès ce début
d'année parce que je crois que c'est
absolument important et on voit bien que
c'est encore ce qui bloque
principalement le départ des
femmes et ça me fait donc rebondir sur
le pack nouveau départ donc je vous le
disais C aller-retour en moyenne
évidemment il y a il y a l'emprise he
exercé du du conjoint vous connaissez
les cycle de la violence avec notamment
les périodes de lune de miel où les
femmes malheureusement reviennent en
arrière et et parfois ont portter
pleainte plusieurs fois mais du coup
renonce au départ et puis il y a pas que
ça il y a des femmes qui sont aussi
déterminées à partir mais qui n'en ont
pas les moyens elles n'ont pas les
moyens financier et donc c'est là
qu'intervient l'aide d'urgence et encore
merci pour le travail réalisé au Sénat
donc cette aide elle va de 243 € à plus
de 1300 €. pour vous donner un exemple
une femme qui est osmque qui a trois
enfants pour avoir une aide de 1337 €
pour partir ce qui permettra donc de
réaliser les premières dépenses
nécessaires au départ euh et puis bien
sûr donc le pack nouveau départ lui est
décorrélé de l'aide d'urgence l'aide
d'urgence c'est sur l'ensemble des
départements à partir du 1er décembre
comme je vous le disais le pack nouveau
départ on a souhaité une expérimentation
raisonnable parce qu'en fait on était
sur le haut départ ça a été mis en place
par ma prédécesseur mais c'était quand
même quelque chose très très nouveau
quiinquiétait beaucoup les services de
la de la CAF à juste titre parce que on
a vu la nécessité de travailler
notamment en terme d'ingénierie pour
réaliser cela aujourd'hui il y a
vraiment on est beaucoup plus confiant
et je peux vraiment vous le confirmer
suite au comité de pilotage que j'ai que
j'ai présidé il y a maintenant une
semaine donc nous nous sommes engagés en
fait à un rétroplanning euh donc mise en
œuvre
donc la tout début d'année donc des des
derniers derni des départements les
quatre autres départements et on fait un
point en avril sur justement les les les
premières expériences de ces
départements et l'idée que j'ai c'est
que si on est s'il y a pas de retour
négatif s'il y a pas de modification à
faire sur le dispositif on je je me
permettrai de de de de l'élargir sur
d'autres départements au printemps avant
l'été pour que on n'attende pas la
généralisation envisagée à fin de 2025
pour tout déployer et donc on pourra
expérimenter sur d'autres
départements tout en respectant bien sûr
l'idée d'aller sur des territoires sur
des départements péurbains ruraux et
également qui sont présents dans les
domes pour qu'on puisse avoir aussi un
maillage et donc qu'on ait une
expérimentation qui puisse être
intéressante à regarder de de près donc
donc je vais pas attendre en tous les
cas l'idée c'est pas d'attendre la
généralisation fin 2025 pour le
faire
[Musique]
euh je crois avoir répondu oui bien sûr
non c'était pas ça c'était sur le le le
pack nouveau départ l'IDE
d'urgence les ordonnances de protection
vous m' vous m'avez alors non pas
interrogé mais vous avez exprimé la
nécessité de qu'elle dure plus longtemps
en effet madame Rossignol l'a évoqué
dans sa question question au
gouvernement hier moi je pense que c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut qu'il faut
regarder et quand on aura l'occasion de
parler de l'ordonnance de protection en
24 vous savez ça ouvre le champ des
possibles en terme d'amendement donc
c'est l'occasion aussi de pouvoir avoir
un débat parlementaire sur le sujet moi
je pense qu'il faut pas le il faut pas
le l'occulté donc c'est l'occasion d'en
discuter là on aura le le le véhicule
législatif pour ça donc ça permettra
d'avoir aussi ce débat dans au sein du
Sénat l'Assemblée nationale pour faire
des enfin pour faire évoluer dispositifs
moi je je je je je m'interdis rien je
m'interdis rien sur ce sujet sur
l'éducation à la vie affective et
sexuelle alors je vous ai expliqué ce
qui jusque-là
bloquait le
déploiement je tiens vraiment à vous
dire parce que moi j'entends beaucoup et
j'entends beaucoup de volonté
euh de toutes les personnes qui se sont
exprimées sur ce sujet mais je tiens
quand même à dire que c'est pas
forcément la volonté de tous les partis
politiques et que ça va pas être
facile la volonté politique si si on est
aussi si on a pu paraître aussi frileux
jusqu'àors c'est bien parce qu'on mesure
combien c'est difficile à mettre en
place c'est
instrumentalisé il y a énormément de
récupération politique sur ce sujet et
donc il faut qu'on soit solide sur cette
question si on souhaite avoir un
déploiement efficace et je pense que
c'est ça qui nous a empêché de le faire
pendant pendant des années je tiens à
rappeler la violence qui a été qui a été
exercée sur Najad Valo belcassen
lorsqu'elle était ministre de
l'éducation et notamment qu'elle a parlé
de la baiss de
l'égalité il y avait des boucles de
parents WhatsApp à l'époque qui donc
WhatsApp existait déjà en 2014 et il y
avait extrêmement euh enfin vraiment de
grande violence et des boucles WhatsApp
de parents qui appelaient à ne pas
mettre leurs enfants parce qu'il y avait
soi-disant dans l'école des cours de
masturbation je le dis ici parce que il
va y avoir énormément de récupération de
la part des plus conservateurs et des
plus religieux donc il faut aussi qu'on
soit prêt à cela et prêt avec un
dispositif qui fonctionne et donc qui
puisse se déployer c'est pour ça qu'il y
a eu donc cette demande au Conseil
supérieur des programmes parce que le
Conseil supérieur des programmes a toute
légitimité à proposer un programme
justement dédié ce qui va permettre donc
de vraiment cadrer les cours qui vont
être donnés à nos enfants et donc il y
aura plus de disparité non plus en terme
de contenu ça c'est évidemment
indispensable et derrière il faut former
alors là on parle du du du du corps
enseignant moi je pense que c'est plus
large c'est le PER personnel de
l'éducation nationale parce que ça
peut-être très bien bien sûr les profs
les professeurs les plus adaptés à le
faire peut-être on pense assez
naturellement au professeurs de de
biologie mais plus largement
c'est-à-dire que ça peut être le CPE ça
peut être l'infirmière scolaire ça peut
être enfin donc c'est c'est c'est
beaucoup plus large que ça et on doit
embarquer pour ça aussi les professeurs
et aussi les parents et donc on a besoin
d'avoir un contenu et besoin d'avoir une
formation des professeurs et d'entendre
en tous les les réticences qu'ils
peuvent avoir sur ce sujet je crois que
nous sommes pas à convaincre ici de
l'importance de ces cours à la vie
affective et sexuelle mais il faut
simplement qu'on s'assure de de de bien
le mettre en œuvre ça nous permettra
notamment d'aborder et je voudrais vous
répondre sur ce sujet évidemment ce
n'est pas des cours de
reproduction même si évidemment il y a
des choses à aborder et ça je crois que
c'est déjà dans les cours de biologie
donc ce sera pas la peine mais
évidemment c'est le consentement le
respect euh les le sujet évidemment de
la pornographie ça a déjà été évoqué
avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale donc c'est évidemment un sujet
qui sera abordé lors de ses cours à la
vie affective et
sexuelle et puis les sujets aussi on
peut aller plus largement aussi sur les
problèmes de santé rencontrés par les
femmes et notamment les sujets
d'endométriose ça peut permettre en
abordant ce
sujet dans un cours à la vie affective
et sexuelle de pouvoir faire un déclic à
à à certaines jeunes filles qui
rencontrent des douleurs parce qu'on
pense encore que les règles sont
douloureuses ce qui n'est pas un
principe voilà mais ça nous a longtemps
été dit quel que soit les générations
d'ailleurs bon donc c'est c'est vraiment
un sujet sur lequel il faut avancer
juste dire je pense que le temps est
compté mais je pense que je réponds déjà
à beaucoup de questions peut-être que
d'autres voulaient poser vous avez
raison il y a un pour les dispositifs
notamment en milieu rural je tirais à
souligner ce que fait la
MRF et qui propose notamment à ce qu'il
y ait un référent égalité sur l'ensemble
des communes et j'appelle à à à votre
vigilance sur ce sujet vous qui êtes
représentant des des collectivités c'est
vraiment extrêmement important de de je
pense de le favoriser dans vos
territoires parce que je suis certaine
qu'en ayant un référent égalité sur dans
chaque commune on peut sensibiliser et
faire évoluer beaucoup de de politique
locale euh et et je et tout le monde a
un rôle à jouer et les communes aussi
donc je pense que c'est vraiment
indispensable de de le promouvoir ça
marche bien dans certains territoires
notamment dans Lyonne parce qu'il y a
une vraiment une volonté politique et la
MRF est extrêmement extrêmement active
et moins dans d'autres départements ça
ça tient ça tend à s'étendre et
d'ailleurs on accompagne également
l'état accompagnement financièrement
cette cette initiative notamment sur le
budget de ma collègue Dominique fort aux
collectivités et vous dire aussi que
nous augmentons les les moyens notamment
du sdfe c'était une demande donc de
votre part il y a 10 nouveaux ETP je
tiens quand même à vous dire que dans
ces temps de
10 c'est pas partout qu'il y a de la
création d'ETP donc 10 ETP que j'ai
réussi à obtenir deux seront dédiés au
départ à au budget sensible au
genre pour justement la mission qui a
été qui a été confié au sdfe et euh à
merci et puis il y a donc h autres ETP
qui seront principalement donc mis sur
les territoires ça veut dire que ça va
renforcer les équipe départementale et
régional donc ça fait 10 ETP au total
supplémentair merci beaucoup madame la
ministre et donc sans plus attendre
Laurence Rossignol puis Lord D'cos et
Marie Mercier merci je vais être rapide
pour permettre aux collègues de tout
pouvoir
s'exprimer en point télégraphique une
question vous vous dit de vouloir renfor
forcer la loi de 2016 vous avez raison
parmi les sujets il y a le la loi en
elle-même et aussi l'application de la
loi et on a un problème sur les
commissions départementales
PSP on a différents problèmes il y a des
départementqu se tiennent bien d'autres
tiennent moins bien c'est assez opaque
sur les raisons du des refus les
associations s'interroge souvent là il y
a un vrai travail de de savez hein parce
que en fait je voulais juste dire faire
voter une loi c'est assez c'est assez
facile d'un certain point de vue tout le
sujet c'est le service àvente de la loi
et service à préente de la loi il exige
un membre de cabinet qui est ça en
obsession plus des fonctionnaires
derrière qui sont dédiés à ça et pas
lâcher voilà c'est pour ça qu'on a on a
et vous n'en êtes pas responsable une
faible politique de l'évaluation en
France et ça nous ça c'est coûteux dans
nos dispositifs donc bien sur le sur la
2016 il faudrait quand même que la fice
passe au niveau du RSA hein c'est quand
même on a un problème avec le montant de
laffice on le sait depuis le départ mais
ça devient quand même de plus en plus il
faudrait que la fice soit PRS au montant
du RSA et vous annonce vous dites
vouloir renforcer la loi est-ce que vous
envisagez de le faire par voie
législative je ne vous cacherai pas mon
inquiétude sur ce sujet euh si on voilà
très bien vouses voilà la ministre
répondu non donc c'est fait voilà voilà
il faut pas y aller ok ça c'est la
première remarque de donc vous avez
répondu à ma question sur toujours dans
l'application de la loi les ordonnances
de protection il y a des départements
entiers dans lesquels il n'y a pas
d'ordonnance de protection c'est je ne
suis pas ou oui je je vois de vos
collaboratries qui feront ses sourcils
ouais euh je crois qu' y a des petits
sujets dans les pri atlantiqu aussi sur
de de de ressort judiciaire euh je ne
crois pas que dans ces départements il y
a pas il y a pas de femmees victimes de
violence et d'hommes à qui on pourrait
infliger une ordonnance de protection
donc on n pas fini le travail sur la
justice euh logement j'attire votre
attention sur le fait que euh les
politiques de les politiques dédiées à
l'égalité femmeshommes au droits des
femmes ne peuvent pas compenser
l'ensemble des euh dysfonctionnements ou
des régressions des autres politiques
sur le logement je suis très inquiète du
fait de la baisse des construction de
logements sociaux et du prévisionnel ça
impacte forcément la capacité des femmes
à trouver des logements une femme qui
vous bien sûr il y a le P nouveau départ
mais si elles ont pas si elles ont pas
accès un logement social
euh c'est voilà bon euh tout le monde
comprend ce que je veux dire euh porno
euh on ne s'en sortira pas euh à essayer
de réguler le porno j'en ai maintenant
l'absolue conviction C elle s'est forgée
au cours de ces deux dernières années
euh et surtout pour entendre ce que
racontent ce que ce que décrivent et
restituent des médecins dans les
services de pédopsie euh qui disent qui
qui sont maintenant se mettent en réseau
parce que un de leur sujet majeurs c'est
des jeunes filles prostituées euh
mineurs il y a toujours une un une
violence sexuelle commise précédemment
enfin subi subi précédemment et euh
deuxièmement euh elles sont euh
totalement influencé colonisé par le par
par par le porno et quand même on a un
sujet assez nouveau sur les violences
sexuelles sur mineur c'est la part des
auteurs mineurs voilà qui je crois
maintenant je je suis pas totalement
certaine de mon chif mais je crois que
c'est la moitié la moitié des violences
sexuelles subies par mineurs sont
commises par des mineurs et là on a de
cette façon absolument certaines du
porno et honnêtement la loi Seren ça
consiste à nettoyer les écuries d'ugas
avec des lingettes
voilà ça on n est pas et après je sa le
temps qu'il faut pour revenir sur un
dispositif
législatif il faut fermer voilà il faut
enfin je crois que notre société devrait
pouvoir dire tranquillement
que la la l'éducation à la sexualité par
le porno n'est pas acceptable voilà pas
acceptable il faut faut parler fort
là-dessus parce qu'on sait qu'on est en
face de nous des des des groupes
d'influence extrême extrêmement
fort dernier sujet un mot sur la loi sur
la question de l'éducation la vie
affective et sexuelle on en on l'avait
déjà évoqué madame la ministre et je
vois que vous çavez vous partagez mon
point de vue à un moment donné il faut
sortir d'hypocrisie et c'est pas au
gouvernement que je m'adresse c'est aux
forces politiques qui sont d'une comment
on veut dire schizophrénie ou dou
dualité de
parole vraiment
troublante on sait très bien que ce qui
pose le principal problème au
gouvernement sur l'éducation de la fé
sexuelle c'est la crainte de du retour
de la mobilisation qu'on a connu sur les
ABCD de l'égalité euh ce que j'appelle
moi pour ma part la convergence des
Lutes des sertêtes et des barbus euh
donc j'aime bien convergence des luttes
des sertêes des barbu c'est-à-dire c'est
le moment où tous les intégristes les
réactionnaires les conservateurs se
regroupent comme on a vu pass passé en
Belgique récemment mais comme ça s'était
passé au moment des ABCD de
l'égalité se regroupe pour bloquer
l'éducation à la vie affective et
sexuelle euh il faut un consensus
politique c'està dire on peut pas avoir
d'un côté des gens de tout à fait
sincères et honnêtes qui interpellent le
gouvernement en disant séquant et d'un
autre côté leurs voisins politiques qui
sont prêts à épouser et accompagner les
mouvements
d'hostilité donc il faut que les
dirigeants politiques s'engagent à
soutenir le gouvernement sur le
programme d'éducation à la vie affective
et sexuelle parce que ces mouvements euh
de associatif et de parents s'ils n'ont
pas de relet politique ou s'ils ont
comme seul rela politique le
rassemblement nation les zmours et le
rassemblement national leur surface leur
capacité d'influence est très limité ce
qui donne la force à ces mouvements
c'est à partir du moment où quelqu'un où
des dirigeants politiques relayent leurs
paroles épousent leur leur point de vue
et leur donne de la force donc j'invite
le gouvernement moi c'est pas ma place
que je vais le faire mais j'invite le
gouvernement le ministre de l'Éducation
vous-même la ministre chargée de la
protection de l'enfance la Ministre
chargée des familles à prendre les tous
les présidents de groupe à l'Assemblée
au Sénat et à leur dire voilà ce qu'on
va faire vous signez ou vous signez pas
vous êtes avec nous ou vous êtes contre
nous mais si vous êtes contre nous ne
venez plus nous parler d'éducation à la
vie affective et sexuelle et aucun de
ceux qui les soutiennent non plus voilà
sinon il faut sortir il faut sortir de
ça euh voilà ce que je voulais vous
apporter comme complément et vous
remercie Mad ah non dernière chose sur
la prostitution rapide je suis très très
très inquiète et je suis pas la seule
sur les Joos euh voilà et alors
j'apprends ce matin qu' avir deux fois
des Joos comme si ça suffisait pas d'en
avoir une
fois non non mais c'est question c'est
pas mon sujetou c'est pas le sujet non
c'est pas lej non non mais je pas voilà
on a deux fois les Jos avec donc c'est
peut-être un peu
différence je retire ce que j'ai dit ça
n'a rien à faire dans le débat d'ici
voilà mais je suis très très inquiète
sur les Jos et je trouve que pour le
moment je sens pas la priorité mise sur
la question de la prostitution et comme
je sais que la priorité va être mise sur
la lutte contre le terrorisme et qu'il y
a des bonnes raisons d'ailleurs de
mettre la priorité je crains que comme
d'habitude on nous explique que le la
lutte le danger de sécurité publique du
terrorisme est va
mobiliser davantage que la question de
la prostitution des mineurs pendant les
JO mais je sais déjà que c'est ça enfin
juste Mad vouz le savoir c'est parti
déjà sur l'organisation de la
prostitution des J il y a déjà des
offres qui sont faites il y a déjà un
pack Jo vous avez un logement une je et
une prostituée avec c'est
parti Lord D'cos merci Marie merci merci
madame la Présidente merci madame la
ministre pour tout ce que vous avez déjà
dit en parlant des violences conjugales
je voudrais aussi parler des violences
économiques dont on parle pas souvent
dans le projet de loi de finances on a
été plusieurs à déposer un amendement
notamment pour que les victimes ne
soient pas également responsables des
dettes dans les ménages on m'a demandé
de réduire la voilure sur juste le
domicile principal mais il faut parler
aussi du patrimoine qu'on peut
avoir personnel ou en tout cas ce qu'on
hein ben c'est ça c'est c'est c'est
exactement ce que j'allais dire flence
parce que le problème c'est que que en
plus on a eu un petit un petit
flottement au moment de du passage dans
l'article 3 le rapporteur général nous a
dit que du coup on avait voté quelque
chose qui ne permettait plus de pouvoir
défendre ses amendements donc j'aimerais
bien qu'au moment du 493 ou en tout cas
av des discussions on puisse en effet
avoir votre soutien parce que c'est un
sujet majeur qu'on puisse essayer de de
faire en sorte que c'est ces victimes
vous vous vous voyez pas madame la
ministre de quoi je vouux parler non
justement je non mais à ce momentl on
pour vous envoyeer nos nos amendements
en fait hein parce que euh du coup ça
était un peu cafouilleux et ça devait
passer en deuxè délibération à la fin de
la première partie ça s'est passé hier
soir je je pense pas que ça ait lieu
enfin voyez voilà donc mais vous
comprenez le principe c'est qu'en effet
bien évidemment que les les les victimes
ne soient pas en plus responsables euh
de de d'ex qui se mettent en
insolvabilité et qui font porter sur
elle euh le poids des dettes et on sait
très bien que les services fiscaux euh
ne regarde absolument pas ce qui se
passe au pénal ou au civil et que du
coup elles ont double peine euh de la
même façon euh dans mon département mais
je pense que ça être ailleurs euh il y a
une une sorte de facilité des procureurs
actuellement quand il y a des problèmes
de de garde euh et d'obligation d'aller
encore chez le père chez le mari violent
euh d'avoir des gardes d'enfants euh
quand il y a un problème quand il y a un
litige
euh la plupart du temps on place
l'enfant en famille d'accueil à laaz moi
je vois parce que j'ai un vrai problème
à laaz qui déborde évidemment ce sujet
mais ça en fait partie et j'ai été
plusieurs fois contacté par des femmes
qui voulai mon soutien et je leur disais
attention parce que les services sociaux
du département m'avaient alerté
là-dessus en disant essayz quand même de
rester dans la médiation avec l'excjoint
parce que sinon la facilité c'est dire
on ne sait pas finalement qui a raison
et et on place l'enfant euh en en
famille d'accueil ce qui est double
peine du coup pour et la maman et les
enfants qui ont qui ont subi ces
violences et alors un autre sujet mais
je fait très vite qui n'est pas de votre
ressort mais je vous demande vraiment
votre soutien c'est mon dada des des
femmes dans le milieu scientifique et
des mathématique j'avais alerté le
gouvernement sur le fait qu'il y avait
plus les maths dans le Tron commun
première terminale l'année dernière ça a
été remis en première mais pas en
terminal donc ça sert strictement à rien
et donc déjà nous étions très très très
très à la traain pour pour avoir plus de
femmes dans les milieux de l'ingénierie
du numérique des sciences et le fait que
du coup on est plus ce programme
vraiment des maths euh dès d'ailleurs le
le qu'on a n pas cette appétence pour
essayer de de susciter des vocations
même dès le primaire chez les petites
filles et jeunes filles va encore plus
creuser ce cet écart par rapport à à nos
voisins et voilà votre collègue
civetillot est bien évidemment
extrêmement alerte sur sur ce sujet mais
on a aussi besoin de votre soutien parce
que c'est de l'interministériel voilà
j'ai fait la plus court de vous toutes
hein oui bravo Lore Marie merci madame
la Présidente je sais madame les minist
que vous êtes très attaché à la
protection de l'enfance on a eu
l'occasion de travailler ensemble et la
présidente Dominique Verrien m'a
spécifiquement chargé aussi de ce sujet
alors je voudrais vous parler du
contrôle de l'âge d'accès dans l'espace
numérique au mois d'octobre perine
Goulet la députée a proposé un un
amendement pour contrôler l'âge d'accès
au jeunum avec un référentiel et le
contrôle de l'arcom dispositif
exactement calqué sur celui que le
ministre barreot a écrit dans la loi
serine or le ministre barreot a répondu
ce dispositif est absolument inopérant
et ne tiendra pas en droit donc je
voudrais comprendre pourquoi pour
contrôler l'accès à l'espace numérique
un dispositif endroit sera inopérant
pour un sujet grand A et opérant pour le
sujet grand B c'est-à-dire l'accès au
films pornographiqu gratuit vous n'êtes
pas le ministre barreau voilà je j'en ai
une conscience aigu seulement est-ce que
vous pourriez voir avec lui essayer de
se coordonner pour qu'on arrive à y
comprendre quelque chose je vous
remercie pour le coup ça aura été bref à
vous madame la ministre c'est vous c'est
vous qui avez fait plus
bref ah si si y en
aaut alors
[Musique]
euh
donc
oui alors vous m'avez interrogé
notamment et je vais tout de suite
répondre sur le sujet de la vie
affective et sexuelle je pense que j'ai
été clair sur la volonté de trouver un
consensus avec les les les partis
politiques raisonnables ce qui ne
créeront pas en tous les cas de
polémiques sur sur cette question et je
pense en effet plus largement c'est que
il suffit pas de dire on va mettre en
place cela et va se mettre en place dans
ces cas-là malheureusement une
récupération et je je je pense que il
faut il faut travailler cela avant parce
que sinon c'est un petit peu comme
beaucoup de sujets il y a ceux qui sont
persuadés du bien fondé de la de la mise
en œuvre des dé cours à la vie affective
et sexuelle il y a ceux qui sont
farouchement opposés et puis il y a ce
ventre mou qui euh se dit ouais
peut-être pas la priorité il y a
tellement mieux à faire et puis en même
temps j'ai des doutes j'entends les
arguments des uns les arguments des
autres et cetera et je crois que c'est
ce ventre mou là qu'il faut convaincre
euh parce qu'en fait il faut tout le
monde n'est pas euh très renseigné sur
la question euh tout le monde ne mesure
pas non plus l'urgence qu'il y a à agir
sur cette question donc évidemment moi
je vous invite dans vos groupes
politiques à à à sensibiliser en tous
les cas autour de vous sur cette
question parce que en effet j'ai des
craintes sur des partis tout à fait
enfin de de gouvernement et qui qui
pourrai être opposé à cela et donc et
donc vraiment je pense que largement il
faut qu'on arrive à convaincre et et
parce que c'est pas si simple c'est pas
si simple que ça mais mais mais oui il
faudra en tous les cas réunir
probablement les représentants des
groupes politiques euh des partis
politiques pour pour pour en discuter
parce que si on veut éviter en tous les
cas que ça s'embrasse sur sur cette
question euh concernant la la
pornographie qui est justement quelque
chose qu'il faut contrer avec les cours
à la vie affective et
sexuelle beaucoup de violence sexuelle
dans les dans les contenus
pornographiques c'est bien le le la la
les conclusions des des travaux qui ont
été réalisés par le par le Sénat et le
Haut Conseil à l'égalité c'est bien pour
ça que je mène aussi ce groupe de
travail euh je comprends
le fait que vous puissiez dire que ça ne
soit pas réalisable non pas que je
l'accepte mais je le comprends parce que
la tâche est difficile
elle est difficile parce que nous avons
quand même des personnes qui sont
clairement opposé au fait de
réguler parce que ça les arrange
bien et
que on est toujours en difficulté parce
que les lois sont toujours plus tard que
les que les dispositifs numériques et
que ça va parfois très vent plus vite
que nous donc moi je reste quand même
plus confiante que vous sur la lois
Seren je la qualifierai pas comme vous
le comme vous le faites là la CMP est
prévue donc en février 2024 le temps de
regarder évidemment au niveau
européen ça nous permettra aussi ensuite
de regarder d'autres dispositifs madame
Mercier sur parce que l'accès étant
bloqué en partie pour les mineurs avec
la loi Seren faudra regarder
l'efficacité de cette loi et pour
l'accès des mineurs au à Internet
c'était surtout les contenus les
contenus dégradants que vous souhaitiez
le éviter qu'il regardent
non non je une réponse technique
pourquoi un dispositif j'entends alors
ça je vais répondre après on est bien
d'accord que vous souhaitez limiter ou
interdire l'accès des mineurs mais sur
des contenus qui sont des contenus qui
sur les sur les sites pornographiques
graphc dans la lo voilà donc c'est bien
le même
objectif on est on est on est
d'accordacès à Internet oui oui oui
c'est pas l'accès à Internet voilà céit
non mais je peut-être d'autres qui
défendrai ça je je c'est pour ça que je
la question peut se poser hein aussi
d'ailleurs peut-être pas au mineur mais
au moins de 13 ans je sais pas s'il faut
aller sur internet quel que soit les
d'ailleurs mais donc donc du
coup donc il faut qu'on enfin faut qu'on
garde sur ce sujet là je dois vous dire
que je ne sais pas enfin je je sais pas
vous répondre euh jeavais pas Avaz pas
entendu parler d'ailleurs de la
proposition de perine Goulet donc je
vous le dis je vous le confesse bien
voilà mais je j'étais sur autre chose
oui c'était donc en octobre et le
ministre Barot est très très mécontent
que cet amendement a été adopté à
l'Assemblée nationale contre son avis
donc j'aimerais que vous puissiez
effectivement donner une réponse précise
et que qu'on fasse la clarté làdus bien
sûr bien sûr bon je vais je vais
regarder ça avec lui ouais c'est ça on
va regarder ça de de plus près
euh madame madame Rossin vous m'avez
vous m'avez interrogé aussi sur ou
surtout fait part de vos remarques
notamment sur sur la la le sujet de la
prostitution donc je vous ai répondu non
il n'y aura pas de loi je crois pas
nécessaire de réouvrir ce sujet je ne
suis pas sûr d'ailleurs que la loi sera
votée telle quelle donc gardons-nous de
modifier quelque chose qui nous va bien
et qui rappelle le la position
abolitionniste de la France euh c'est
indispensable on va regarder là le
travail est en cours euh pour pour faire
en sorte de de mieux appliquer la loi
euh le montant de la fille c'est un
sujet aussi donc on va regarder là je
rencontre pas tout non on consomme pas
tout voilà exactement donc ça veut dire
que ce n'est pas assez attractif entre
guillemets c'est pas assez attrayant
pour pouvoir être être utilisé donc il
faut qu'on regarde comment comment on
peut faire évoluer cela pour justement
que l'enveloppe affice soit utilisée
dans son entièreté donc pareil je
m'interdit rien je travaille avec les
les associations là je vais les
rencontrer dans les prochaines semaines
et le plan sera annoncé au mois de
janvier enfin pas le plan pardon le
le la stratégie la stratégie la première
he parce qu'il y a jamais eu de
stratégie dédiée donc sur sur le système
prostitutionnel et je vais le présenter
avec Charlotte cobel aussi parce que je
suis on est bien conscient donc de de du
fait qu'il y a de plus en plus de
mineurs qui se prostituent on est très
inquiet des chiffres et donc c'est
vraiment un travail commun qu'on va
mener et donc on aura l'occasion de vous
en dire plus euh au mois de au mois de
janvier dire que le sujet de la la
prostitution concerne bien sûr les Jeux
Olympiques et ça je l'ai pas du tout mis
de côté je le m' enfin je m'en suis
inquiétée dès mon arrivée en
responsabilité euh on a en effet des
véritables packages euh de de voilà de
de des séjours touristiques qui prévoi
aussi des euh des des des activités
sexuelles c'est assez effrayant euh je
pense qu'il y a une chose enin il y a
plusieurs choses je pense qu'il faut
sensibiliser tous ceux qui arrivent sur
notre territoire pour cette période
parce queil y a des il y a des personnes
qui
justement et
honnêtement ne mesurent pas notre loi
c'est-à-dire que la enfin la position
abolitionniste de la France est assez
isolée on le sait et donc pour beaucoup
c'est pas un sujet je la prostitution
dans leur pays elle est c'est pas
interdit et donc il faut qu'on rappelle
la position qu'à la France et pour ça on
est en train de regarder pour une
communication dédiée justement pendant
les Jeux Olympiques moi j'ai sensibilisé
mon collègue Gérald armmanin sur la
question donc on est on va voir comment
agir justement sur cette période pour
euh justement traquer les ceux qui qui
vont donc chercher ce type de de de
service ça c'est c'est indispensable et
puis je crois qu'il faut aussi qu'on
qu'on puisse sensibiliser en amont dans
les ambassades et ça j'ai prévu de le
faire en début d'année prochaine parce
que ça coûte rien non plus de passer par
les ambassades qui peuvent aussi
sensibiliser au départ les les personnes
qui viennent dans notre pays rappeler
tout simplement la position
abolitionniste de la France et que et
rappeler aussi les peines encouru et
l'amende encouru pour pour pour faire
appel à ses activité
sexuelle juste on avait aussi parlé des
OP c'est pas le la corise mais le Cantal
qui ne délivre pas d'OP dans dit donc
les en effet les ordonnances de
protection je note ma ma conseillère a
sourcillé parce que je pense vraiment
qu' c'est voilà c'est on l'apprend mais
on va regarder ça de très près et en
effet ce sera intéressant en effet sur
les 6000 ordonnances de protection qui
ont été délivré de regarder quel est le
le maillage et quels sont les
départements qui sont les plus concernés
et en fonction aussi le rapport le
rapport habitant habitant nombre
d'ordonnances très intéressant Paris est
à
regarder
voilà on a donc vous avez tout mon
soutien sur les mathématiques euh
j'étais hier à l'introduction d'un
événement à HC mais j'en fais d'autres
sur la mixité ça faisait donc 50 ans que
HCC a a ouvert a ouvert ses portes aux
femmes et en fait moi je rappelais lors
de cet événement et dans bien d'autres
que en fait on n est pas c'està-dire que
et et je crains qu'on est encore une
génération sacrifiée c'est-à-dire que
les chiffres n'augmentent pas
euh alors réforme ou réforme d'accord
elle a elle a elle a elle a fait du mal
on est en train de rectifier je je ça je
on l'a dit on le mais c'est bien en
amont et et même d'ailleurs sans cette
sans cette réforme du bac on avait de
toute façon un problème donc je je c'est
c'est vraiment extrêmement compliqué
mais à bientôt monsieur le
sénateur et donc évidemment il faut
qu'on arrive à à à améliorer cela moi je
pense
Infiné mais je sais pas si tout le monde
partagera mon avis mais euh qu'on devra
aller vers les cota
je on a essayé beaucoup de
choses c'est alors les quotas suffisent
pas parce qu'il faut aussi donner envie
enfin je veux dire à un moment donné si
on donne pas la la la possibilité en
tous les cas aux écoles de pouvoir
remplir ses quotas mais à un moment
donné on devra obliger d'une manière ou
d'une autre et ça a fonctionné en
politique ça a fonctionné dans d'autres
cadres et je je je crois que ce sera une
des solutions à à une des pistes pour
faire en sorte qu'on ait davantage de
femmes dans un certain nombre de
filières je je je reste persuadé mais en
tout cas j'en suis inquète école
scientifique bien
sûr des
écoles sur des écoles de
filles Scien tech ce genre de
sujet bah ça fera partie du débat
puisque de toute façon c'est un sujet
sur lequel nous allons travailler sur le
je voulais finir quand même sur répondre
sur le sujet parce que vous avez pas
vous avez été rapide donc je dois je me
dois de vous répondre quand même sur le
sujet de des dettes dans le couple les
sujet de la fiscalité hein
globalement c'est un sujet qui est
complexe c'est un sujet qui est complexe
parce que euh les les situations sont
diverses et moi la question je l'ai
abordé j'ai vu Tomas casenav hier et on
a abordé ce ce sujet euh ensemble
euh c'est c'est difficile de de
d'imaginer des dispositifs uniquement
dédié aux femmes victimes de violence
conjugale parce que je je le dis c'est
un sujet qui concerne énormément de
couples la mise en insolvabilité euh du
conjoint de l'ex-conjoint et
euh je j'ose le dire parfois un sport
national
et je je
je% je j'ai pas ces stat je me
permettrai pas mais si vous le dites je
vous crois bien volontiers et donc je
crois qu'il faut qu'on arrive et moi je
disais à Thomas casdav notre urgence
c'est absolument justement de lutter
contre la mise en insolvabilité d'un
certain nombre quand vous avez deux
personnes dans un couple qui sont
salariés la dette elle repose sur les
deux parce qu'ils sont salariés donc on
pction sur le le le salaire du conjoint
autant qu'on ponctionne sur le salaire
de Madame c'est évidemment injuste pour
madame qui n'a pas contracté ses prêts
ou fait ses dépenses mais il y a un
partage c'est quand même différent de
celui qui s'organise totalement son
assolvabilité lorsqu'il est par exemple
artisan et qui fait couler sa boîte se
met en insolvabilité remonte une boîte
et puis après s'organise pour que les
versements se passent sur un autre
compte peut-être même sur le compte de
la nouvelle conjointe et ou alors même
bah du coup fait un petit peu de BL en
attendant pour pouvoir passer cela et
surtout bien embêter madame donc j'ai
bien conscience de la situation je dis
juste que la la la difficulté c'est de
trouver des solutions à cela et donc moi
je pense que la la première des
batailles c'est de lutter contre
l'insolvabilité et donc de regarder ce
mécanisme de de de de du fait d'avoir
cette tant de facilité pour faire couler
sa boîte et en remonter une autre on a
tous des des des des personnes autour de
nous sur lequel on pour pourrait en tous
les CASF regarder ce qui ce qui ce qui
s'est passé dans ce couple là dans ces
couples qui nous entourent on a tous un
exemple autour de nous et donc je je
j'ai pas trouvé je vous dis je cette
réflexion je l'ai mais pour l'instant on
n pas trouvé vraiment quelque chose qui
pourrait être extrêmement utile et
faciliter la vie de ces femmes on a
quand même agi c'est-à-dire que on a
déjà réduit vous savez les années c'estd
fallait 10 ans on regarder 10 ans en
fait de situation fiscale alors que
maintenant on regarde plus que 3 ans
donc c'est déjà un énorme pas qui a été
fait jusqu'alors mais c voilà moi je
suis prête à à le travailler à regarder
tout ce qui peut être organisé mais je
je souhaite aussi vraiment qu'on
s'attaque à la mise en insolvabilité
d'un certain nombre qui est
insupportable et qui est injuste et sur
le sujet de l'autorité parentale
euh alors il y a il y a plusieurs choses
il y a la PPL déjà Santiago issu donc de
l'Assemblée nationale qui va permettre
d'avoir une automaticité donc de du
retrait de l'autorité parentale enfin en
tout le cas de retrait de la garde ça
c'est quelque chose d'acté et qui du
coup sera ce sera plus simple c'est
quelque chose qu'on avait pas réussi à
faire dans la loi de 2020 donc comme
quoi on avance au fur et à
mesure il y a le rapprochement du civil
le civil du pénal avec avec les les
pôles spécialisé qui on espère va aussi
avoir une incidence sur les les les les
décision notamment sur les gardes
d'enfants et puis on est également
partagé par la volonté d'un certain
nombre d'agir sur davantage de garde
alterné je vous rappelle quand même donc
je on est on est on a de plus en plus de
pères qui s'investisce dans la dans la
vie de leur enfant et c'est bien heureux
et en même temps on a ce dilemme avec
ces violences exercées sur les femmes et
où le la garde d'enfant devient à un
moment donné le le le le sujet pour ce
pour se se se battre entre les entre les
les anciens conjoints donc c'est c'est
c'est toute la difficulté mais en tout
cas sur le sujet des violences on avance
avec notamment cette PP heureusement que
tous les couples ne sont pas non mais
non heureusement madame la Présidente
voilà victime de violence ce quiarrive
dans dans des procédures non
consensuelles c'est ceux dans lesquel
justement la
majorité heureusement pas toujours on
peut aussi ne pas s'entendre sans
forcément qu'il ait il a initialement de
la violence Rais financière
aussi pas que les violences euh ce sera
doréavant colombe
Bruxelles anilerou et Marie- laore
finera h merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente merci madame la ministre et
merci pour cet échange je je voudrais
revenir sur les questions d'hébergement
et d'hébergement d'urggenence je vous
entendais dire alors d'abord des choses
factuelles le nombre d'hébergements
aujourd'hui en France moi j'avais de
23000 en tête vous avez dit 220000 mais
je vous propose qu'on se batte pas et
que je fasse la promo du du gouvernement
euh je vous entendez dire que il y avait
des places supplémentaires pour les
femmes victimes de violence au au projet
de loi de finances sur lequel nous
sommes en train de débattre et
travailler c'est
exact et pour autant euh la la question
euh qui me vient mais qui nous vient
c'est est-ce que ça répond au besoins
euh et forcé de constater que la réponse
est non h alors on a les estimations qui
ont été faites par la Fondation des
femmes sur la question de l'hébergement
des des femmes victimes de violence il
manquerait quand même quelques milliers
de places par rapport au au besoins
estimés par la Fondation des femmes
hypothèse basse euh et puis finalement
le sujet c'est celui que vous avez
évoqué c'est celui des priorités vous
aviez cet échange en réponse à à la
question posée par anque
billon je voudrais reprendre un exemple
du territoire que je con le mieux je
suis sénatrice de
Paris la question des priorités elle
nous fait faire et je vais je vais dire
nous parce que c'est un nous collectif
de la société elle nous fait faire des
choses folles aujourd'hui à Paris
lorsque vous appelez les 115 je vous
fais pas l' laillus sur appeler le 115
laavir tout ça quand vous appelez le 115
les critères de priorité sur de
l'hébergement d'urgence c'est d'être
enceinte de plus de 7 mois et d'avoir un
bébé de moins de 3 mois enin
remettons-le en version négative ça veut
dire que si vous êtes enceinte de 6 mois
et demi que vous avez un bébé de 3 mois
et un jour vous n'êtes pas considéré
comme prioritaire par le 115 pour être
hébergé c'est aujourd'hui la réalité à
Paris la réalité à Paris c'est
que sur les personnes je redis qui ont
appelé le 115 je prends des chiffres
d'octobre 2023 ils sont pas encore
consolidés pour novembre c'est 1129
restés à la rue malgré leur appel au 115
c'est 856 personnes en famille donc 413
enfants aujourdhi ourd'hui on a sur les
trottoirs de Paris des femmes pardon ce
sont majoritairement des femmes
extrêmement majoritairement des familles
à la rue dont une énorme proportion de
femmes on va dire ça comme ça qui sont
dans la rue aujourd'hui ce sont des
directeurs et des directrices d'école
qui ouvrent des salles de classe pour
que des gamins scolarisés ne dorment pas
dehors devant l'école et vraiment enfin
voilà sans eux qu'est-ce qu'on ferait ce
sont des familles des parents d'élèves
qui se mobilisent et de de nouveau
heureusement que cette mobilisation est
là ce sont des ouvertures parfois un peu
sauvages je le reconnais bien volontiers
de bâtiments inoccupés puisque avec la
pression des des parents d'élèves des
directeurs d'école le lycée inoccupé
vide Suzanne Valadon vient enfin d'être
ouvert pour
accueillir des enfants et et des femmes
à la
rue enfin voilà la réalité dans laquelle
on est j'entends tous les chiffres et je
n'en disconviens pas mais je je veux
vraiment qu'on se redise aussi que à
force de prioriser dans une situation où
on ne répond pas aux besoins on en vient
et je redis je dis on on en vient à dire
et à faire des choses folles et moi je
ne peux pas accepter qu'on se dise que
une femme avec un enfant de 3 mois et un
jour est une femme dont l'hébergement
n'est pas prioritaire et qu'on considère
dans ce pays qu'un enfant de 3 mois et
un jour il peut dormir dans la rue euh
voilà et du coup euh interpellation je
pourrais terminer par une question un
peu facile de vous dire que sortant de
cette audition qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que je dis euh en en votre nom euh au au
nom au nom de la France aux familles qui
se mobilisent et je veux surtout vous
alerter et vous sensibiliser sur le fait
que
euh on ne parle pas que de chiffres euh
mais on parle aussi et surtout je crois
de de réalités qui sont terribles à
vivre bien sûr
Annie moi
je pense merci an louerou euh moi je
reviens sur merci pour madame la
Présidente et merci madame la ministre
pour vos réponses aux nombreuses
questions qui ont déjà été posées moi je
reviens sur le pilotage et sur les
équipes des rdfe et ddfe vous avez dit
10 équivalent en plein don H8 dans les
équipes régionales il y a 13 régions et
100 un département donc ça fait pas
beaucoup de moyens supplémentaires on
sait que ce sont des politiques on vient
de le voir à travers des les questions
qui ont été posées qui sont
transversales
interministériales un travail avec les
collectivités territoriales et les
équipes sont très à la peine en fait
pour démultiplier finalement et porter
euh la la politique et déégalité femme
homme mais aussi de violence faite aux
femmes dans les dans nos départements
euh voilà sur les ordonnances de
protection donc beaucoup a été déjà dit
sur le pilotage je pense aussi et c'est
lié aux ordonnances de protection il y a
pas suffisamment de formation
transversal il y a eu d'énormes de
progrès qui ont été fait police
gendarmerie mais en terme de formation
on a besoin de croiser les expériences
entre les associations le les
professionnels du droit les les
policiers les collectivités
territoriales et ça aussi c'est le rôle
des équipes de pilotage qui n'arrivent
pas à le faire et son les ordonnances de
protection moi dans mon départ artement
il y a énormément de demandes qui sont
faites et qui malheureusement ne sont
pas prononcées donc ça aussi je suis
dans les codes d'Armor donc c'est
intéressant de voir quel département les
prononce mais de voir aussi au Prat de
la population mais aussi au Prata des
demandes qui sont faites par par les
femmes je reviens pas sur la
prostitution un mot sur les auteurs je
fais peut-être erreur mais il me semble
que
c'est important de se préoccuper des
auteurs il me semble que
l'accompagnement est pris sur le budget
euh droit des femmes ce que je trouve
moi un petit peu contestable je pense
que c'est plutôt à budget justice
puisque le ministre se targue d'avoir
augmenté les
budgets sur l'accompagnement des auteurs
les auteurs payent mais aussi les fans
payent pour accompagner les auteurs je
trouve que c'est une bonne chose
d'accompagner les auteurs je regrette
que ce soit pris sur les budgets
d'accompagnement et des associations qui
accompagnent les femmes victimes de
violence et je m'arrête là euh voilà
donc ensuite c'est Marie- Laor finira
mais surtout je précise Olivia Richard
aussi puisque c'est la dernière donc
comme ça vous avez les deux dernières
questions à toi Marie merci madame la
Présidente merci madame la ministre
d'avoir apporté des réponses aux
questions posées précédemment par contre
moi je vais vous emmener euh dans une
autre France la France
ultramarine donc je ne sais pas si vous
connaissez la Guyane si vous la
connaissez pas je vous invite à nous
rendre visite pour toucher les réalités
de ce territoire alors pour relier
Cayenne en partant de la commune
amérindienne Camopi c'est vrai qu'il
aurait fallu avoir la carte mais je
pense que par les mots vous allez
comprendre il faut pas moins de 48
heures de trajet ces conditions rendent
très compliqué l'intervention de la
déléguée régionale au droits des femmes
et récemment d'ailleurs elle
m'expliquait que qu'il lui était
impossible d'organiser la prise en
charge des femmes victimes de violence
dans cette commune enclavée de Guyane
madame la ministre que pouvons-nous
faire pour éviter la double peine à ces
femmes victime à la fois de
l'éloignement et des cûts des hommes la
Guane également est très confronté au
phénomène des grossesses précoces ou non
désiré en cause la sous-utilisation des
moyens de contraception le ministère que
vous avez en charge annoncé il y a
quelques mois
une mobilisation en faveur de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes dans les
territoires ultramarins il a été
notamment question de l'accès des femmes
à la santé et de l'adaptation des
campagnes de prévention et
sensibilisation pourtant une responsable
du réseau périnade guyan indiquait il y
a peu qu'il subsistent des obstacles
pour accéder à la contraception que
comptez-vous faire pour faciliter
l'accès à la contraception en Guyane je
vous remercie et Olivia
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre je suis sénatrice des Français
établieurs de France ça
existe nous avons évidemment nos nos
difficultés nous avons la particularité
de vivre dans des pays de loi étrangères
comment dans ces pays faire respecter
une égalité comment tenir certains
discours vous avez dit tout à l'heure
que les ambassades serait prié d'avoir
une campagne de communication pour les
touristes qui viendrai en France pour
les Jos je suis un peu interpellée
euh c'est alors quel budget quel moyen
parce que pour faire cette campagne je
très bien euh lafe qui est l'opérateur
public en matière d'enseignement
français à l'étranger puisque il y a des
écoles françaises à
l'étranger est référent ànor pour
l'égalité hommes-femm en matière
professionnelle ils sont également
associé à de nombreuses
associations pour l'éducation des
enfants et néanmoins on voit par exemple
au Maroc dans certains lycées récemment
le retour de d'élèves voilés qui sont
évidemment voilz plus ou moins et
évidemment les portes de l'établissement
leur restent ouvertes puisqu'il n'est
encore une fois c'est un contexte très
particulier mais comment peut-on
travailler sur cette question
travaillez-vous avec le ministère des
Affaires étrangères et la eufe sur ces
questionsl et enfin les violences non
pas de frontière et on a euh observé par
exemple de cas de femmes en France dont
la police ou la gendarmerie leur a
expliqué qu'elle ne pouvait pas être
protégée leur a ils leur ont conseillé
de partir et par exemple j'ai j'ai j'ai
cette en tête cette femme qui a dû
partir en Irlande pour se mettre à
l'abri elle travaille aujourd'hui dans
une ferme bon comment on peut venir en
en aide à ces à ces femmes euh être
victime de violence à l'étranger c'est
la double peine aussi parce qu'on est
prisonnière dans son foyer parfois on ne
parle pas la langue et il suffit de voir
son passeport confisqué pour être bloqué
bien sûr les postes consulaires sont là
aussi pour leur venir en aide mais quand
on a des enfants on na pas le droit de
les ramener en France c'est un
enlèvement euh donc comment on peut
travailler sur ces questions
merci alors merci madame la Présidente
alors déjà vous répondre sur le sujet de
l'hébergement je je je suis vraiment
très consciente des des tensions qu'il y
a sur les territoire et particulièrement
à Paris
euh on est confronté à à des demandes
très fortes quel qu'ell soit quel que
soit leur nature d'ailleurs quelle que
soit la nature de la demande et vous
avez raison j'avais un chiffre en tête
de 220000 mais ça doit être 223000 je
vous crois bien volontiers c'est pas
parce que le chiffre augmente vous
m'ariiez dit 217 je vous aurais cru de
la même manière mais j'avais j'avais
dans la tête 220000 places d'hébergement
d'urgence
h la priorité reste les femmes je je
j'apprends les critères d'attribution de
ses places à Paris je sais que la
tension y est très très forte et
j'ignore pas non plus qu'il y a parfois
des femmes qui viennent d'accoucher et
qui doivent rester à l'hôpital plus
longtemps parce que on ne à juste titre
on ne souhaite pas les remettre à la rue
donc je n'ignore pas je je vis pas dans
un dans un voilà dans quelque chose de
doré où je ne verrai rien de ce qui se
passe j'ai bien conscience de ce qui se
passe sur le sur le terrain
eu on a malgré tout en île-de-fance
c'est quand même 27 % du parc global
c'est-à-dire je vous ai dit qu'il y
avait plus de 10000 places d'hébergement
d'urgence dédié aux femmes victimes de
violence c'est 2687 places en
Île-de-France donc l'Île-de-France c'est
bien pourvu sur ce
sujet la difficulté c'est d'avoir de
pouvoir gérer les différentes demandes
parce que beaucoup de femmes dans un
parcours migratoire rend compte des
violences et donc on les aide de la même
manière qu'on aide nos concitoyennes
victimes de violence et c'est là
qu'adevient aussi les tensions et
notamment aussi quand on a d'autres
publics qui sont déjà présents dans les
places d'hébergement cont tenu qu'on a
du mal à trouver des
hébergements
donc intermédiaire ou même de façon
pérenne c'est plus compliqué donc pour
pour héberger il est là notre elle est
là notre problématique parce qu'en fait
les personnes dans les centres
d'hébergement restent trop longtemps et
donc on a des difficultés après pour les
faire les les les faire partir pour
libérer des places quand même vous dire
que depuis que nous sommes arrivés en
responsabilité on a attribué beaucoup
plus de places notamment dans les
logements sociaux pour les femmes
victimes de violence on est à 12000
attributions par an alors que nous
étions seulement à 7700 700 en 2017 donc
ça montre bien notre volonté de de de de
faire en sorte que les les femmes
puissent trouver un logement
intermédiaire ou même un logement pour
du plus long
terme voilà donc moi je ce point que je
vais faire sur sur les hébergements en
début d'année va permettre aussi de de
regarder de faire vraiment un constat et
je serai très transparente avec vous sur
ce constat l'idée c'est pas de cacher
une réalité qu'on ne voudrait pas voir
vous m'avez interrogé a sur les
ordonnances de protection madame la
sénatrice 2 ti3 des ordonnances de
protection sont accordées donc je ne
sais pas quelle est la réalité de votre
territoire mais vous vous m'avit
interpellé en tous les cas à plusieurs
sur la situation de certains
départements donc je pense qu'on va
regarder très clairement l'attribution
des ordonnances de protection par
habitant donc ou même par fait de de de
violence donc à la connaissance des
forces de l'ordre pour voir le ratio et
puis également le nombre d'ordonnances
de protection donc enfin ouais prononcer
voilà donc on va moi je je vais regarder
ça parce que ça ça m'intrigue et je veux
je veux en savoir plus sur les places
dédié aux auteurs écoutez déjà je pense
qu'il y a eu un un gros chemin de fait
sur ce sujet parce que je rappelle quand
même que moi je me rappelle très bien
des discussions de 2019 il était hors de
question d'aider les auteurs pas un
centime pour aider les auteurs aider
enfin traiter parce que il est pas là
pour leur tendre la main dans l'idée de
dire que on pardonne tout c'est de dire
on met pas un centime sur les auteurs
bon les choses ont évolué et même les
associations aujourd'hui conviennent
bien volontiers que 40 % de récidiv à un
moment donné on s'en sort pas donc il
faut évidemment traiter les autres
auteur vous m'interrogez sur les places
les places d'hébergement dédiées à ces
auteurs mon ministère finance 492 places
je vous rappelle
10492 vous avez raison on pourrait
penser et d'ailleurs le ministère de la
Justice en prend à sa charge 165
supplémentaires qui sont payés par le
SPIP
aujourd'hui il y a des places
d'hébergement qui sont pris en charge
par par le le le garde par le ministère
de de la
justice écoutez ces places d'hébergement
elles sont déjà pas pas utilisées dans
leur entièreté hein vous dire que les
492 places que je finance elles ne sont
pas enfin le le le le budget n'est pas
totalement utilisé parce qu'on n pas
cette culture de sortir les auteurs du
domicile à juste titre he la priorité
c'est bien de protéger les victimes moi
je je tiens pas le discours de dire il
faut sortir les auteurs quoi qu'il quoi
qu'il advienne non la priorité c'est de
sauver les femmes et de s'assurer qu'il
n'y ait ni de féminicide ni
d'infanticide donc c'est bien de de de
de protéger oui la question peut se
poser de savoir sur quel budget ça
repose moi en
attendant que la politique se déploie ça
ne me dérange pas que ce soit sur mon
ministère parce que je considère que je
m'assure que ces places elles soient
bien attribué bien financé et mon budget
je le gère vous dites le ministre se
targue d'avoir eu une augmentation je
tiens quand même à dire plus 40 % de
plus début du Mondial c'est plus que
starget c'est quand même une réalité
donc je tiens quand même à à redire que
le le le ministre ministre éc duupti a
obtenu la hausse la plus significative
de la 5e République sur ce sujet donc
qu' quand même lu lui lu lui redonner ça
donc la question elle se peut se poser à
terme elle se posera peut-être pour
l'instant écoutez les places sont pas
toutes utilisées et honnêtement elles
sont même souvent vide parce que il y a
pas assez cette démarche d'aller mettre
les auteurs dans les les sortires de
l'hébergement pour pouvoir laisser les
femmes et les enfants à la maison donc
regardons moi je suis très très
confiante sur les centres de prise en
charge pour auteur je vous disais 14000
auteurs ont été accompagnés l'année
dernière je mise beaucoup dessus parce
que il faut absolument qu'on arrive à
arrêter cette spirale des violences et
il y a que le traitement des auteurs qui
peut le permettre on peut pas que
soigner les plis il faut aussi qu'on
traite le mal à la racine et le sujet
des auteurs en éteint c'est primordial
de les traiter donc si ça passe aussi
par le financement de place
d'hébergement pour les mettre en
condition aussi euh les faire se sentir
coupables euh dans une démarche
d'accompagnement psychologique
traitement des addictions et puis
également euh une réinsertion
professionnelle tant mieux les places
d'hébergement ont leur importance parce
que elle permettent il faut qu'elle soit
bien qu'elle qu'elle soit bien présente
sur sur le territoire et non pas qu'à
côté du centre de prise en charge pour
hauteur pourquoi parce que les centres
de prise en charge pour hauteur il y en
a deux par région donc on a vraiment
fait un un effort considérable d'avoir
30 centres sur l'ensemble de de du
territoire français mais la difficulté
c'est que euh quand vous avez une
personne qui travaille il faut surtout
pas qu'elle arrête de travailler
l'auteur il faut qu'il continue à
exercer sa profession pour justement ne
pas se retrouver en précarité et qu'il
aille vraiment dans une démarche de
traitement et donc ça reste le
traitement psychologique des addictions
mais qu'on qu'il puisse continuer à
avoir son son son métier donc
l'équilibre est pas est pas simple mais
mais en tout cas moi je pour l'instant
en tous les cas ce ce ce budget repose
toujours sur mon ministère et on verra
comment les choses évoluent mais
j'entends votre remarque sur la sur la
question la question m'a déjà été posée
l'objectif est partagé à 100 % de ce que
vous venez de dire c'est l'imputation
sur le
budget je tiens d'ailleurs oui oui non
mais tout à fait le le c'est bon
j'entends je je les ça se défend ça se
défend juste pour dire d'ailleurs en
terme de de taux de récidif parce que du
coup aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu
difficile de de mesurer le taux de
récidive notamment des auteurs après le
passage dans les CPCA parce qu'ils sont
assez récents ils ont 2 3 ans euh mais
vous dire que le centre de prise en
charge
d'aras agit depuis des années he depuis
presque 10 ans maintenant et en fait ils
ont de très bons résultats ils sont
passés de donc quelqu'un qui rentre
enfin il y a 40 % de récidiv alors que
du coup on à la fin du passage dans ce
CPCA c'est 13 % donc ça montre bien que
que qu'on peut agir aussi sur ce sujet
sur le sujet vous MZ interrogé sur les
posts en région euh je vous ai parlé
donc de 10 postes supplémentaires 10 ETP
deux cons sacré donc au budget sensible
au genre dans un premier temps les huit
autres les priorités vont être données
aux régions qui vont qui accueillent des
pack nouveau départ et également dans
les outres mèes ça me fait rebondir
madame la
sénatrice sur le sujet de de la Guyane
vous relevez une réalité terrain que je
ne suis pas venu voir de mes yeux mais
que je je connais je sais qu' a il y a
il y a beaucoup de sujets et beaucoup de
difficultés notamment en Guyane et vous
vous l'avez d'ailleurs dit avec
notamment les temps de trajet qui font
que c'est très difficile pour les jeunes
filles d'avoir accès à un certain nombre
de choses don déjà dire que on agit
notamment sur la sur le sujet de la
contraception d'abord parce que il y a
un appel à projet de 500000 € qui a été
lancé en juillet 2023 pour soutenir
notamment les les projets qui prévoi de
renforcer des actions en matière de
santé dans les
outr-mer ça vise notamment à améliorer
l'accès à la contraception également des
actions des des également des des des
difficultés en couche que peuvent
rencontrer les les femmes et puis
également sur la santé prénatale des des
des
enfants donc cette commission nationale
elle a retenu 38 projets à mi-novembre
dont SEP sont situés en Guyane notamment
comme le projet oyapoc coopération santé
euh il y a également donc l'accès aux
préserv masculins qui sont remboursés
donc pour tous donc ça c'est important
il faut aussi le faire connaître dans le
département de la guyan parce que c'est
absolument important que les que les les
les jeunes et moins jeunes se protègent
lors de leur relations sexuelles on a
aussi on m posé également une deuxième
question en 2021 il y a trois des cinq
départements et régions d'outremè qui
figureent parmi les 10 départements avec
les taux de violence conjugal les plus
élevés euh donc c'est la Guyane la
Guadeloupe et la Réunion et la Guyane a
le taux de féminicide le plus important
en 2021 avec un taux supérieur de 1
pour000 donc on met en place des
dispositifs il y a l'appel à projet qui
a été lancé conjointement avec le mefh
et le myum structuré autour trois axes
déjà l'adaptation des des campagnes de
prévention et de sensibilisation et
d'information aux spécificités du
territoire notamment l'utilisation de la
traduction et le doublage en langue
locale moi c'est très important parce
que je l'avais vu lors de avait fait
donc lors du grenal des violences
conjugales on s'était déplacé avec
plusieurs députés sur différentes
différents départements et notamment
aussi sur des départements d'outr-emè et
c'est quelque chose qui nous a été
beaucoup remonté donc pour ce sujet il y
a 38 projets retenus dont SEP en Guyane
pour un montant de 94000
€. il y a également des permanences
juridiques de proximité qui peuvent
aider les femmes qui sont
particulièrement victime de violence
intrafamiliale et ce projet donc de
22000 € ont été proposé sur les 22900 €
demandés donc là on est
vraiment très enfin on essaie de de
suivre ça de très près notamment sur les
moyens financiers c'est des permanences
qui permettent notamment d'aller à la
rencontre du
public et de leur proposer un
accompagnement et une information
juridique accessible quitient compte
justement des spécificités géographiques
après évidemment tous les dispositifs
qui sont
disponible donc sur le territoire
métropolitain est également disponible
dans dans les dans les domes ça c'est
indispensable moi je sais qu'il y a un
gros sujet dans les département d'outrer
c'est aussi le fait que les gens
connaissent tout le monde et ça pour
quand on parle de de l'éviction du du du
domicile et de partir précipitamment et
de se cacher de son conjoint violent on
se cache où alors en guyan peut-être un
peu plus qu'ailleurs mais sur l'île de
la guadele
loupe c'est plus compliqué compliqué
voilà donc ENF on est bien conscient en
fait hein de de de cette de cette
difficulté il y a aussi des dispositifs
de santé donc d'accompagnement à la
santé je pense notamment à la Maison des
Femmes vous savez que la première
ministre s engagé à une maison des
femmes par département c'est on continue
le déploiement on y met plus de 6
millions d'euros encore en 2024 pour
accompagner ce dispositif on y croit
beaucoup un dispositif qui est
complémentaire au travail réalisé par
les associations déjà de quotidiennement
de depuis des années donc vraiment vous
dire qu'on voilà on est extrêmement
vigilant et et je sais que le Philippe
Vig est particulièrement vigilant aussi
sur sur la question bien sûr des outres
mères parce que c'est son portefeuille
mais on a eu l'occasion en tout cas de
d'échanger sur la sur la
question madame la sénatrice euh vous
m'interrogez alors je voulais
rééclaircir mon propos il s'agit pas
d'une communication auprès des
ambassades mais bien une sensibilisation
auprès des ambassades par contre il y a
bien une demande auprès de l'cret pour
réaliser une communication mais en
France à destination des touristes pour
leur dire que ici on n'a pas le droit de
d'avoir des activités sexuelles tarifées
et que notre pays est abolitionniste
donc je voudrais voilà je voulais
rééclaircir le propos l'idée c'est bien
de sensibiliser au niveau des ambassades
parce qu'on est très conscient que ils
peuvent eux faire en tous les cas un un
un travail auprès des des ressortissants
le sujet que vous aborderé est un sujet
complexe parce que je mesure les
difficultés pour en avoir beaucoup
discuté pendant le précédent mandat
lorsque j'étais député avec Amalia
lacrafi qui est aussi donc député des
Français de l'étranger et qui me
soulignait que les dispositifs n'étaient
pas adaptés ou en tout cas ne répondez
pas à aux difficultés des des des femmes
qui vivent à l'étranger des Français de
l'étranger et je connais les les
difficultés parce que je sais combien
elles sont isolées vous l'avez très bien
rappelé je vais pas redire évidemment la
la situation que enfin les situations
que traversent ces femmes et et pour ça
je je pense je pense qu'il faut qu'on
regarde encore pour travailler au niveau
des des ambassades parce que c'est bien
eux nos interl enfin c'est eux qui font
le le voilà c'est c'est c'est c'est eux
qui peuvent aider en tous les cas à la
communication auprès de ces publics il
faut qu'on arrive davantage à
sensibiliser les ambassades sur sur ce
sujet pour que en fait ils puissent
trouver des solutions d'accueil pour ces
femmes qui fuiraient le domicile et qui
se retrouveraient aussi en difficulté
notamment sur le sujet des papiers mais
je suis prêt à en parler avec vous et
qu'on avance plus spécifiquement sur ces
publics qui sont des publics spécifiques
mais ils n'empêche sont des des français
bien sûr et quand vous me dites ça
existe je l'ignorai pas et bien sûr ils
sont très nombreux à vivre à l'étranger
il faut qu'ussi qu'on leur apporte
protection c'est bien les engagements de
la
République et bien merci beaucoup madame
la ministre d'avoir pris tout ce temps
aussi pour nous répondre avec beaucoup
de détails je vais vous demander encore
une